[Musique]
un torchon brûle dans la marmite de
mercadal thérèse allez vite vous
dissimulez l'oeil dans un trou de
serrure j'entends prédit fkih vos
lumières mon tremblay ces messieurs de
la bourse cette époque n'en peuvent plus
d'attendre
l'associé prodigue ou l'associé félon
selon les joues vous les circonstances
s'est associé là c'est une clé qui ouvre
plus aucun terroir en attendant prêter
mois vécus dans la tente d'en livrer moi
vous fourrure de l'eba vos bijoux
motards hausse du crédit de la vaisselle
fine du linge brodé mais ne te concierge
le père cru bon faire sa fac se
connaissent et pourtant c'est le portier
parfait son oreille traite dans toutes
les belles et à l'ama toujours tendue au
métier du monde reste chaque il répète
aussi aisément la vérité qu'il habille
le mensonge aux mesures du client la
vieille canal le bonnet enfoncé sur la
tête de la part de me donne des frissons
se regarde personne le corps je passe en
courant dans sa loge et il est partout
on ne voit jamais bien terrestres le
carrousel comment juste at oui mercadet
prévenu n'a de merci monsieur mercan est
extrêmement fatiguée monsieur beaucoup
de nuits sans sommeil je crains qu'il ne
repose encore vous ne m'attendrir est
pas mon ami je demeure inflexible
bien entendu justin le tapage que fait
monsieur dès potron minet monsieur
monsieur bré 10 de votre propriétaire
tiens à vous parler seul ait pu
l'empêcher d'entrer mercadé je suis hors
de moi et vous mes coups très jeune à
vous louer un appartement de 11 pièces
auxquelles paris rue de gramont et pour
2500 francs jfr 3000 points tous les ans
heureusement vous me trouvez ci terme
vos meubles sont saisis et je ne ferai
pas en faire partie des meubles
et vous vous êtes le vtt le petit matin
pour courir en civil un chagrin long de
nos semblables
vous n'êtes pas mon semblable monsieur
vers canet vous êtres criblé de dettes
et moi je ne dois rien je suis dans ma
maison et vous êtes bons locataires et
qualité ne sera jamais qu'un vain mot
nous serons toujours divisée en deux
castes les débiteurs et les créanciers
si subtilement bobet les anglais allez
soyez français cher brachet infiniment
cher de j'aimerais qu'ils bougent et là
j'aimerais mieux toucher mes loyers mon
infiniment cher monsieur mercadet alors
soyons sérieux tout seul de mes
créanciers qui poussait biens et
d'argent réel
il ya 18 mois vous avez fait ces sermons
mobilier qui voudra bien 15000 francs
soit près tout je ne voudrais deux
années de loyer que dans quatre mois
les intérêts de mon capital je les
plaies a demandé par voie de justice je
me laisserais condat lui je ne fais pas
de spéculations
je vis de mes revenus vraiment serais-je
si tous mes locataires vont ressembler
non non non il faut enchaîner le jeu
près du pont danois qui a vu depuis onze
années dans votre maison blanche assure
y eut enfin vous connaissez mes déboires
vous savez que je suis victime d'un abus
de confiance dogbo allez vous encore me
chanter cette histoire de la fuite de
votre associé je la connais par coeur et
tous vos créanciers la satoci et puis
pourquoi calomnier godeau il était homme
d'énergie belle fourchette pour vivant
il vivait avec une petite femme
délicieuse laquelle il avait un enfant
et ils ont abandonné
duval votre ancien caissier sa décharge
et bordeaux s'est chargé de la caisse il
vous à emprunter 150 mille francs
violemment j'en conviens mais elle vous
a laissé toutes les autres valeurs de la
liquidation et vous avez continué à
faire vos affaires depuis huit ans vous
en avez fait d'énormes vous avez gagné
des batailles à la pyrrhus
ça nous arrive souvent à nous autres
spectateurs godeau vous a promis de vous
mettre pour la moitié dans les affaires
qu'il allait entreprendre oz
il reviendra bien attendez le ainsi vous
toucherez les intérêts de vos loyers
voilà un bon classement
vos raisons sont éloquentes mais si tous
les propriétaires écoutait leurs
locataires
les locataires figuraient tous par les
payer en raison de ce genre et le
couvert à la salle gouvernement n'a pas
le temps il peut s'occuper de requins
des personnes oui mais il veut c'est à
repos et ne se paye pas lui avec des
raisons c'est pourquoi je suis à mon
regret forcé d'agir avec les groupes
nous vous que je crois le chiffon
ignorez vous que je vais marquer ma
fille enfin laissez pas conclure un
mariage vous en serais allé madame
prédisent donc sera ainsi vous serez
payé demain c'est demain vraiment je
serait navrés de refroidir les ardeurs
de votre jambe mais tant pis vous avez
dû recevoir un petit commandement
avant-hier et si vous ne payez pas
aujourd'hui les affiches seront apposées
demain alors franchement monsieur bré
dif
que puis-je vous proposer pour gagner 3
moore mon cher mercadet une conscience
un peu stricte s'accommoderait mal de
cette complicité involontaire car le jeu
contribue à laisser éblouir votre futur
gendre mais je suis un homme bon au oui
j'aime l'amour mercadé renoncer au droit
de sous location que vous donne votre
bail et je vous donne vos trois mois de
38 av m'assassiner dieu un homme par la
troublante ressemble un morceau de pages
de nos invités chaque fois son idole un
couteau voyez nous sommes en 1839 propre
aida cette année à tous
les loyaux heureusement pour nous autres
de cabine je sais que nos trois barbus
congédierait et ma pauvre faveur à
perdre une ressource de cette sous
location dans le canevas yeager le gros
mot
il ne supporte pas les maudits les
débiteurs les plus honnêtes sont souvent
corrompus par adresse qu'auteur de
certains créanciers qui sous prétexte de
retrouver tel que sous côtoie la loi
jusqu'à la frontière vole monsieur je
suis venu pour être payés non pour me
faire insulter sans me rende la teinte
pire que le cri le crime ou des nazis la
tête vous met à la porte
la rue monsieur leroux cela ne
renonceraient à mon endroit
monsieur je ne veux pas d'un
consentement ainsi arraché et bien je
vous remercie de tout mon coeur ou très
vite
j'étais très nerveux je suis très vivant
comprendre je suis attaqué de toutes
parts mais créanciers ne veulent pas
admettre que je lui tends pouvant les
pays c'est-à-dire pour continuer à faire
des affaires comme le husa la bourse
c'est ma vie alors terminons derechef
notre petite transaction laïcité sans
doute chez vous je vous prie de son
mieux j'aurai donc mon appartement dans
trois mois également vu domestique j'ai
trop de mal à voir la péta à ce pauvre
mercadet il a beau savoir nager
il se noiera voyez-vous les belles
aujourd'hui la déconfiture du maître
retombe sur les domestiques
je suis forcé de payer tout ce que
j'achète c'est une vie est ce que ces
grands comptes ont comme ça monsieur
justin
j'ai déjà servi dans plusieurs maisons
bourgeoises mais celle ci est unique
vrai nom je vais laisser les fourneaux
et me présenter à un théâtre bourgeois
la commune faisant pas autre chose que
des moutons quoi se faire crier aussi
ils vont viennent
ok tu monsieur reste des heures entières
à l'écouté ils sont tous riches ils ont
cependant donné leur argent monsieur
tunnel europe
ces voleurs sa robe empruntait n'est pas
volé écoutez virginie je prend de
l'argent dans votre sac à votre insu
vous êtes paulet mais nuance si je vous
dis
virginie j'ai besoin de sang soo pointer
les mois alors vous me les donne et je
ne voulais rendrait pas je suis gêné
momentanément je vous promets de vous
rembourser plus tard vous devenez ma
créancières
mes gars je me sens du ca veux laisser
mon compte livrer mon livre de cuisine
les fournisseurs n'avaient plus vendre
sans recevoir d'argent
moi je ne prenne pas de moi la raison
avec la mono d'âge moi je pensais rester
je veux savoir comment ça finira car ça
m'amuse
et puis ma demoiselle va épouser de
petits mineurs mais ça change tout c'est
un mariage
nous aurons des gratifications il faut
rester jusqu'au lendemain des noces mais
croyez-vous que ce soit ce petit gratte
papier qui ne gagnent pas 10 800 francs
que monsieur mercadet mariera sa fille
mais j'en suis sûr ils s'adorent ils
s'adorent mais attendez plutôt cette
nouvelle je le concierge vient de me
dire que deux jeunes hommes magnifique
était venu dans un cabriolet somptueux
leur cochet a dit au père grumeaux que
la de hal et épousé mademoiselle julie
or monsieur avait donné 100 francs au
père grumeaux oui et pas promis donner
en argent et il lui a si bien fait la
leçon que le père grumeaux a dit au
coach et que monsieur été si riche qu'il
ne connaissait pas lui même sa fortune
je ne sais pas monsieur mais je le crois
capable de tout même de devenir riche
souvent ce petit le voile a perdu les
affiches fleurissent sous la porte
il reçoit des rames de papier timbré et
à notre chat il rebondit il triomphe du
nouveau tous les jours des actions du
bois changé en pavés des actions des
châteaux des duchés des moulins des
actions du cuivre de l'étain de l'or
disque on planche is a mis en action
un jour monsieur secousses a battu le
lendemain il se réveille millionnaire il
chiffre
il calcule il ne dort jamais il écrit
des prospectus qui sont comme des pièges
à loup il s'y prend chaque fois de
nouveaux épargnants
cependant il a beau lancer des affaires
il a tout vu
curieux frère tout emporté résolu à le
faire chanter en prison il leur parle
ils finissent par rire ensemble les une
sorte les meilleurs amis du monde pour
tes sens pour tous comme moi des gens
comme pierre et petit gros tu se nourrit
de piller nuit c'est toujours la
meilleure moyenne
goulard mais dan lé second père qui
voudraient mais ce comté les riches les
garçons mais c'est vous faire j'entends
madame qui vient avez-vous des monsieur
madame c'est le seul sanctionné
monsieur mercadé n'est pas chez lui moi
je suis très inquiète
monsieur parlait avec monsieur bré dit
madame est assez juste un madame est
sans doute contrarié on a refusé de
livrer les commandes aux fournisseurs
laval plusieurs crédits gelés créanciers
sont responsables à je pouvais leur joué
quelques bons tours le meilleur serait
de les pays il serait forte plus les
affaires de monsieur mercadé me donne
bien du souci nous aurons besoin de
votre discrétion
nous savons que nous pouvons compter sur
vieux jonc évidemment normal nous ne
devons pas laisser voir notre jeune
provisoire
il se présente à un riche parti pour
mademoiselle sud où ils méritant d'être
oméga canon signal c'est un cri doté à
une jeune fille tous ses moyens de lui
refuser robes manteaux sacs chapeaux
si madame veut bien le dire le nom du
prétendant j'irai chez tous les
commerçants ja signerait que je puisse
envoyer chez eux ce monsieur monsieur de
l'abri de la bri a pris pour payer le
trousseau madame et nous le livrerons
voilà comme vous parlez à votre mystique
ils vont m'apprendre sp demain dit à
monsieur à les instants chez monsieur
marc nolin le prix est de venir me
parler tout une affaire qui ne souffre
aucun retard bien soyez assez mystérieux
il faut qu'ils viennent ims thérèse
retourner chez tous les fournisseurs
madame merkel dites-leur ses choix
d'apporter ce qui a été commandé par
votre médecin
ils seront payés oh oui payer autant
aller j
madame vous at elle donné ses ordres
vous vous distinguez aujourd'hui nous
avons quatre personnes adieu monsieur
personnel sa femme mary queen mary 2
méricourt et monsieur de la prime ainsi
seront cette saisie de là sur la pop est
haute et grands depuis hier ayez pour
ouvrir le ban ap otages onctueux puis un
beau poisson depuis quatre ans très
finement pas comme les messieurs alors
au second concerne les cieux almarcha
web à 100 me parler de marche le jour
sont contre ma fille soit france est
elle plus rien fournir vous irez chez
leurs concurrents
et vous leur donnerez ma clientèle et
vous offriront un d entre elles s'il me
demande d'être réglé je réponds de rien
car je touche moins le crédit et toute
la richesse du poids mais fournisseurs
mais que des traits les lois de leurs
pays
il serait pas constitutionnel et
anarchistes s'il me laissait pas quand
même cassé pas les oreilles avec des
gens en révolte contre les principes
vitaux qui fondent l'état payé cordons
bleus ne prêtait pas ma forte attitude
détruit associer les ciels jeu vous fera
gagner de gros intérêts 30 % l'an c'est
fou tu me connais pas il y en a plein le
dos ou blanches
vous mettez votre argent on traduit
assez trop cher mais vous avez lâché
d'esprit faut le faire valoir vous même
je prends moi écouter me temime chez moi
et si votre petit magot ne vous
quitterai pas ce traitement
gfr les 18 du milieu veut cette fille il
est qu à la caisse d'epargne qu'elle
nous a volés du rex qu'on abat dames
c'est un prêté pour un rendu mon ami
jusqu'où des cendriers monde amis à vous
quel est votre autorité d'existence quel
organisé beaucoup de vous soucier de
rien bien installé dans votre petit
confort
donc ils sortent tous les soirs avec
votre ami monsieur d'amérique ou qui
m'avait demandé la compagnie d'un public
oui on peut pas être à la fois à sa
femme épouse a fait notre compagnie bref
vous qui faites la belle élégante à vous
ne l'avez sort devenir fou
le fond une femme et l'enseigne des
spéculateurs comme vous retrait l'opéra
dans une robe somptueuse des gens 10
euros les asphalte vont fort ou bien la
40e' fonds chair et en os bada mercadé
encore une nouvelle toilette doivent
être la combinaison sur les rachats des
services militaires soit agréé par le
ministère de la guerre vous aurez une
voiture
[Musique]
damiot ne le croyais pas que ce qui vous
touche me laisse indifférent jugez pas
de moyens dont je me sers blanc n'est
pas la bonne manière oui n'obtiendrait
rien pas la douceur de sa part commenté
payet mans comme napoléon ordonné canton
de pays bon eh bien justement on paye
d'audace on prête à obtenir par
l'affection des services qu'on refuse à
aa l'autorisation aux propos mort
d'homme vous connaissez bien notre
époque mais aussi madame les sentiments
s'en vont les pouces n'a plus que
l'intérêt par cap de collectivités des
individus chacun pense et agit pour soi
fondé du plateau pour du sucre ou si
vous avez su faire fortune sans
provoquer de plainte
vous devez député académiciens au
ministre et à dire pourquoi les drames
dont les héros sont des scélérats autant
de spectateurs c'est parce qu'ils les
admis et néanmoins se retrouve à flatter
en disant je vote une même mieux c'est
kokal - madame moi j'ai mon excuse je
porterai poids du crime de godot mais
qu'at-il de si déshonorant de voir tous
les états d'europe ont des dettes et l
oms il ne meurt pas insolvable envers
son père il lui doit la vie il peut pas
rentrer ne suis-je pas supérieur avec
les amsif j'ai leur argent ils attendent
le mien fortement dollar game over
pouvez vous me dire où commence et où
finit la probité dans le milieu
commercial de l'avocat de capital
certainement nous a comblé le ça choque
personne
nous devrons un sou personne alors le
plein de pas les moyens que j'emploie
conserver ma place au grand tapis vert
de la spéculation
tu fais quoi à puissance financière tout
crédit un pic à mensonge on devait
l'aider à cacher notre misère sous les
diamants de luxe chic vous apitoyer sur
mes créanciers bon dieu il a vendu leur
argent car
à vis du tout madame avidité
l'actionnaire et le spéculateur se
valent tous deux veulent être riche en
un instant t les jours avant que ciani
sané contemporain et quoi tous tirer
quelque chose de moi je connais assez
sûrement leur fils et leur passion pour
jouir à chaque le dénouement mais il en
est qui sont la vapeur autres partis
tenez goût par exemple il est féroce et
ils vous forcera à déposer votre bilan
jabel de bobby moore les mines d'or soit
poussé mexique at la bouche et je
demeurerai debout jusqu'à que j'ai
trouvé mon fils
avez vous rencontré sur monsieur o c'est
pour m'amuser
et chose rare de voir il faut s'y
prendre dès le matin savoir profiter du
moment où la porte est ouverte et les
gardiens s'absorbe le quartier sont
venus de pécs aux vans vous est
impayable
non je suis intégré monsieur mercader ça
c'est drôle ça c'est très drôle ça ne se
joue la recette
je ne me contenterai pas de paroles de
parole je sais il vous faut des actions
bon matériel j'avais tout un tas pour
votre paiement si vous voulez nous
plaisantons pas je viens avec
l'intention d'en finir
non monsieur commence plutôt de prendre
mal à me laisser parler de ce goût là
vous êtes chez vous écouter vous
permettez je suis très heureux que
madame intervienne car sa signature
pourrait amener certains à fès non pas
votre parfum fabas temps de se guérir
d'une autre conversation les femmes
n'entendent organisme a mis le
secondaire s'est montré aussi au pardon
or il ya le réclamer le montant de sa
créance en argent liquide
by pas ménagé au mieux un valet au vu de
ma poursuit bien dans ma vie qui
pourtant vous avez réalisé des capteurs
considérable attention des affaires où
tout n'a pas été bénéfique ou sur aimait
répéter ça me donnait que des bénéfices
tout le monde pour aider à faire il n'y
a pas cherché des preuves de votre
esprit vous en avez plus que moi puisque
vous avez mon argent ils font 4 l'argent
sakata pas sa couleur a beau ne mettrait
mal conduit à un autre que moi se
vengerait alors et la possibilité en ce
moment
je suis sans rancune mauvieux je peux
vous faire perdre de somme fantastique
et vous ne payez pas je crois bien mais
vous ne jouerez pas au plus fin vous me
verrez où je remettrai demain votre
dossier entre les mains de la justice ne
sont pas les paroles ne s'agit pas de ce
coach vaudois
sur ce chapitre vous n'avez aucune
inquiétude mais moi non plus le web os
d'état plutôt plus importants sont en
jeu
oui vous nous narguent avait stupéfié
littéralement tapas sortie comment vous
un homme beaucoup de tissus à l'esprit
city comme vous avez vous pu vous
engager dans cette affaire si bien on a
tous des moments de distraction
pouvez-vous dire vite même de ne pas
jamais vous avez qu'elle a fini par s'y
connaître en spéculations elle a un
flair pour les usa saluent une autre
baby macéra les couleurs l'a acheté
elle capte de l'anglais bah quoi à la
fin vous le savez on s'est toujours le
pas nous plaît à mes yeux je vous ai mis
sur la voie je peux pas vous en dire
plus vous voulez parler des mines de la
basse indre
c'est une affaire venait ou une uc
unique pour ceux qui ont vendu y est on
là on se crée dans la coulisse les
informe des bars vous allez par la
baisse aujourd'hui et demain surtout
demain mais quand on saura ce qu'on lit
à trouver des cailloux là rien que des
cailloux merci mr cadette
le conseil vaut que nous causons plus
tard de nos petites affaires
madame et aux marques quand il arrive
n'est pas long c'est la grande nouvelle
elle vous rassurera donc un peu sur
notre créance
jean-marie baffin non plus tard je suis
pressé mais juliette ou d'un
millionnaire je vous fais mes
compliments puis sa lettre monsieur ait
son âme
je voulais dire vous pouvez compter sur
moi pour la circonstance interactive
vous savez des valeurs sûres doux noms
comme un bel sont pas légaux siens pour
quitter tindouf et reçus venaient voir
comment vous parfois lundi finement
comme dubaï alors tant mieux mais je me
laissais ma part je me sentais que ça
tient du produit rien à faire pour le
retenir il va tourner le dos comme un
livre à une faute est alors que
j'appelle du programme
lui avez-vous dit la vérité au moins moi
même je ne sais pas d'aimer les deux
sens de vos parents mon univers de
l'inde à organiser une sorte de panique
à la bourse sur les actions émises de la
parcelle d'entreprise ce était
hasardeuse de la mirifique tout à coup
s'il venait à réussir je me ferai ma
part et ceci nous ramène mariage de
julie je sème
j'ai besoin d'un second moi-même pour
accor
mais si vous m'aviez prise comme
caissier nous aurions au moins trente
mille francs
wada le jour où j'aurai eu 38 francs de
rente suisse est terminée au but un peu
si nous nous étions enterré dans
quelques provinces avec le peu d'argent
qui nous serait resté à près d'1 point
fort c'est pour çà fait ce monstre de
godot on sent que je demande auriez-vous
connu monsieur de méricourt qui vous
plaît tant que et de qui vous avez fait
votre emprunt se consomme ce lion dans
cette région enfin nous débarrasser de
julie
la pauvre enfant n'est pas notre plus
bel achat les deux hommes sensés qui
pensent que la boue dépasse
il en allait de puissance et qui pensez
que la laideur demain je ne me sentais
pas la marchandise
je ne suis pas monsieur de la bim sa
passion subite mais c'est qui le savoir
ce qui a pu le charme et dans ma vie en
julienne et this year de ce sont sa voix
est délicieux elle est instruite
sensible elle lit des rentes ne l'écrit
pas qui prouve qu'elle est une fille
d'esprit
reste à espérer qu'elle comprendra le
mariage comme toi le comprendre de femme
en homme d'affaires
mais brown est toujours tout l argent du
tapis de modestie après trouver l'amour
est à remplir vos obligations del valle
de la faire jolie madame halimi le
monsieur et les virtuoses et spiritueux
ça son mari aura bien de la russie
gréement givry en mon enfant patron fait
des mois devant vous partez sur un sujet
toujours ça créera une jeune fille il se
présenta parti pour vous papa tu vas
peut-être te marier mon enfant comment
peut-être mais cela doit être reçue
sacré gaby mme dorion mais si mineur
vous aideront pas rayer mon petit papa
ça c'est le qu'on l'attendait vous
madame mercadé a trouvé un monsieur
ménard établi dans le coeur de votre
fille
les saints jt de ce petit employé dont
du vam au caissier m'a parlé mais le
fils naturel de godo est posé vous
l'aimez oui
[Musique]
s'agit pas des vu pourrait être émis
vous aimez regard ne sortait pas de ce
mouton nourrissent cette majeure
vous êtes une personne au fait on pour
toi vers la politesse de la prime à la
casse a calé les bénéfices de sa
fraîcheur et sa beauté bien minutes
après mon père je me fâche répandre
quelques rêves avez-vous de tram et de
quelles preuves
on avait du bon dieu
[Musique]
et voilà et voilà les filles or comme
les petits enfants des réponses comment
passer le raisonnement vous n'avez vous
rencontrer ici encore le soir ce que
vous êtes sorti il est il plus chaude
que vous de quelques mois paie au bas ça
fait beaucoup d'années trente ans plus
tard je les sers veulent et ne peut pas
apprécier tout toutes vos qualités
il m'a remarqué le premier un soir chez
madame duval nous avons dansé ensemble
dans le débat se fait une spécialité
d'inviter des jeunes gens sans
opposition les madmoizelles venait d'en
sont les garçons qui danse n'ont pas
d'avenir
ce ton de la vie sont frais d exemple et
ne dansent pas estompée en soit voilà ça
oh là là oh là là monde dit à ma vie
c'est peut-être pas moment de faire des
réflexions stupide
tu sais peut-être pas moment l'heure on
passe on pense à dos à dos et il
s'appelle adam
les imbéciles présente notre beau de
progress
apprenez trip à tour leurs employés à
tous enfants ne sait pas aimer il a pas
tant il est construit cité se doit
d'abord au travail le travail de trail
il est né pour ça
contre les propriétaires les nantis les
oisifs l'édile est un peu sorti question
de ducos julie votre faire-part l'europe
c'est ce que je lui reproche au chili je
lis je te donne à temps monsieur ménard
attend pauvres abuser
t'as pas le premier franco du cadre et
vous le lendemain du mariage il ya qu un
seul mensonge eu une conversation durant
et après on peut on peut je ne suis plus
tromper un oubli ton père l'hépatite hop
hop hop donc on fit date et que nous
éviterons un petit appartement au
sixième sous les toits je serai
sincèrement je m'occuperai du ménage en
mieux j'ai travaillé pour lui pendant
qu'il travaillera pour moi l'amour nous
aidera à passer les moments difficiles
adolphe de l'ambition il est de ceux qui
a vu le garçon au l'arrivée pour ce que
tu as dit que les familles à dole à tant
de volonté unis atteint moyen que je
suis sûr de le voir un jour chef de
service dans une administration publique
[Musique]
oui ministre 50 on sait rien faire
d'autre on délivre
et précisément il faut bien savoir faire
pour le devenir
là c'est comme l'amour de chasse gardée
la société ne bouleverse pas parce
qu'elle fait le malheur des pour elle
est exigeante et la saison et je défie
les sens il s'agirait d'une petite
amourette qui ne repose sur aucune base
sérieuse
ces deux partis d'autres un amour auquel
nous sacrifions tout à gauche quand
l'étude apposition fortune je suis
incapable d'avoir commis la moindre
indiscrétion qui peuvent compromettre la
gauche et ne croit riches
il ne m'a jamais parlé d'argent bon ben
je suis maintenant julie écrivez-lui
immédiatement de venir me parler
merci papa je vais rien décidé ah
j'adore élégant et dans ta peau ne
manquera de distance va me dire qu'il
est ici il vous recherche
voilà mon candidat s'il d'écouté vous ne
serez pas madame li na mais vadam de la
vie s'y prête pas la femme d'un ministre
est babouche aurait peut-être celle de
l'ambassade de france
jfh et ma fille d'avoir lieu
n'aimeriez pas mon cher père et
permettez moi d'accepter tout simplement
le bonheur et la pauvreté au revoir ma
fille marque touareg et pour une fois le
tout vous dans 7 à l'union fait la force
c'est la devise de la majorité au
parlement
et c'était pas de bonheur possible dans
la vie il n'est pas de malheur que la
fortune
si je vends ma mère qui prononçait des
paroles si triste mais jugez vous
pourrez juger m de là brive
comme vous y serez le séminaire il vous
n'aurez pas le choix mais je suis à mon
avis c'est l'été mais pas se tromper
c'est toi ce problème j'aimerai toujours
l'être ainsi mentionné nous n'avons
personne pour ouvrir la récession a
surtout laissé seul
je m'imagine toujours que god oh put
revenir vous attendez encore coteaux
vous me fait l'effet que ses députés
battue qui espère toujours une élection
anticipée
[Musique]
c'est une sonnerie tréand si je dis vas
voir et pas compter qu'ils répondent que
ta mère et moi sommes sortis
il aura sans doute la plus peur il la
croira peut-être en bas une vierge je
ressens même où sa série au couple au
dedans romanès que vous autres les forts
le premier amour
il s'agit d'une bonne affaire pour sa
tanière pour lui julie que tu te laisses
aller écouter ton milliard ça qu'on soit
bien enclenchée suis là je sais comment
le ferry leucémie ne soyez pas trop
tarder
je ne viens pas vous demander de
l'argent à mon cher frère cadet je sais
que vous faites un super de mariage
notre fille épouser un millionnaire ou
le bruit s'est répandu via cette
nouvelle heureuse à cannes et vos
créanciers
moi même j'ai retiré ma plainte il me
faire arrêter en garde et jamais des
dossiers très longtemps pour vous
remettre des parties de mes principes je
vous ai laissé deux angles mercadet si
ce mariage est une attention je vous
fais mon compliment le retour de godo su
c'est diablement un genre vous fera
gagner du temps n'en faites vous m
vous êtes ingénieur des couleurs à doper
l'hameçon mais qu'aviez-vous mis dessus
et il est fin pourtant goulard m'ont
chambré monsieur de la bri un jeune
homme et les agronomes je vous le ferai
pouvoir alors combien payez-vous john a
menacé dans sa relance
autrement mon cher je vous demanderai de
régler le compte
et vous perdriez beaucoup aux primes
vendée large
il voulait régler je m'entends cela je
crois pas je vous rapporte autant que le
faire mon goût mais la naissance là je
venais vous proposer une chance de
valeur contre laquelle je vous accorde
un sursis de trois mois
asseyez vous mourriez c'est ça va la
faire vous savez moi je suis lucide
limpide avec moi on y voit parfois trois
ans je vous ai jamais reproché de
pratiquer l'usure allusion y est c'est
un capitaliste qui prend sa part tu
avances
tenez voici les 13 pour cinquante mille
fois émanant d'un fort joli jeune homme
nommé michelin
elles sont en règle le protège jugement
par défaut jugement définitif au ces la
balle de carence dénonciation
contraintes et cetera et cetera bien sam
ils font ça vous ou nous pouvons admirer
jeune homme maintenant contrat d'avant
beaucoup d'ingéniosité pour vie nous
savons à moins qu'ils épousent une
anglaise fortune est amoureuse de lui et
non d'un titre je songe elle ma lâcheté
mais cela lui jeter dans des intrigues
de chancellerie il me faut par
conséquent en échange des choses de même
valeur croît des actions de vos
entreprises qui ne donnent plus
dividendes et vous m'accorderez un
sursis de 5 - 1 nous un an j'ai dit aux
amours à kaka malgré mon intelligence ce
fabuleux je ne vous comprends pas mais
je suis votre ans j'avais compté là
dessus voici la lettre par laquelle il
accorde un sursis
voici les dossiers michaud n'a oublié ce
jeune homme a mis tous les huissiers de
paris sur les doors il m'a découragée
vous n'êtes plus retors que moins
coûteuse trop peu s'il est heureux de
vous livrer un lit tournant dans ma cage
aux folles circulent et maintenant vous
voulez vous les actions rose d'un
journal qui pourrait avoir du succès
s'il paraissait en voilà
les actions plus d'une mine qui a sauté
over les actions jaune de pavés qu'ils
ne peuvent même pas saturation des
barricades
donnez nous toutes ses couleurs toutes
les couleurs se marient
on va là on voit là on voit la balle est
bien pour 48 merci on sait rami ça fait
plaisir nous autres nous nos rendements
les affaires à les placer mes actions
mais oui à toute leur valeur
si c'est possible elles vont le
remplacer vos lions sans panier pour
frégates sont les barbots police
sensible in tous vos objets fabuleux
ceux-ci vieux oui et puis le tribunal
commence à trouver ça un peu léger au
pire cet homme grand l homme dit vous
avez ranimer mais pas le voyez mon bon
mercadé que je le voudrais
ben moi go vous savez ce que je ne
souhaite pour le mariage de votre fille
à dieu a mis un vieux canapé
juste un match d'ouverture
on a pu faire de maître qu'il arrive
monsieur il a eu raison de l'argent à
donner à monsieur bré dit fut fait en
sorte qu'ils me parlent
avant d'entrer chez prédit non mais t'as
bien entendu autre chose j'ai tous les
enfants ont bien cru ball concierge il
peut pas encore par manque pour
s'enfoncer
non monsieur dont on plaît que je lui ai
fait croire qu'il disait la vérité juste
que tu finiras par devenir mon
secrétaire et là je me suis nécessaire
de savoir écrit il ce crétin des
ministres écrivent très peu le font-ils
dans ils font le ménage et il parle
qu'on leur patron doit se taire quand on
sait comme rose toi pour que donc le
père bruno di aver de l'ain que braid iv
sorti
citoyen c'est merveilleux dès que j'ai
promis le paiement du solde des
marcheurs est devenu commercial
comment je comprends le commerce moi
ancien abri
or on nous a guidés à votre mesure
messieurs ne mangera et les bus et là
les épiciers autres tout est foot il
patientera et ça paye et les bas si
maintenant les ulis marie alphonse
rassemble notamment messieurs et moi je
te donnerai pour marie un des futurs
employés de la compagnie d'assurance
contre les risques de recrutement chaque
bonne condition en monsieur soyez
tranquilles je connais leur de rendre un
prétendu amoureux fou et je sais aussi
comment le rendre froid oui je me suis
vengé de ma dernière patronne en faisant
rompre son mariage la langue d'une femme
de chambre c'est un roman d'anticipation
domestique
monsieur nô réellement nous n'avons pas
tant de talent on a le droit de rêver à
voir ces gens pour soi
t comme si le gouvernement avait la
presse a dit monsieur monsieur faire
part ensuite aux notes vous souhaites tu
fermes ta propre marionnette tu peux pas
faire long depuis 11 ans gars m'ont
servi tu sais pas quoi faire elle est
partout
allez va causer spirituel ma vie car de
là jusqu'à ce que j'aie conjuguée aux
pauvres une de vos victimes
oh je suis déjà venu en soit depuis huit
jours son excellence monsieur merkel et
le besoin mais obligé de vous attendriez
dans la rue pendant trois heures en me
promenant d'ici à l'impôt j'ai vu qu'on
m'avait dit vrai en m'assurant vous
étiez à la campagne non nous sommes deux
malheureux pour votre père violette nous
avons tous les deux une famille nous
avons engagé de ce qui peut se mettre au
mont-de-piété c'est comme ici le salon
est restée vie le mâle de l'un ne guérit
pas le mal de l'autre mercader vous avez
encore de quoi vivre et le pain nous
manque
vous ne reconnaîtrez que je ne vous ai
jamais reproché ma ville je crois que ça
vienne attention nous enrichir et puis
c'est ma faute j'ai voulu doubler notre
petite fortune est gelée compromise ma
femme et mes filles ne veulent pas
comprendre elle qui me poussait à
spéculer elle qui me reprocher ma
timidité elle s'obstine à nier que
saisir la chance de gagner beaucoup
c'est s'exposer à perdre trop enfin
parole n'engendre pas farine avant je
viens vous supplier de me donner un
petit un tout petit acompte seulement
sur les intérêts vous sauverez la vie à
tout une femme gentille dame n'est pas
gentil part quand je vous quitte je
déjeune de mauvais à pitre or
raisonnable maintenant des êtres
fraternelle et partager nous avons à
peine 100 francs la maison et encore de
leur jeune fille est ce possible vous en
excellence monsieur mercadé l'oeuvre que
j'ai vu syrie et autres malheureux on se
doit la vérité si on se devait ksa
comment ce père répond tu mens n'abusez
pas de cette confidence mais je vais
marquer ma fille j'ai deux filles moi
mon excellent monsieur elle travaille à
vous fendre l'âme sans espoir de se
marier les films année qui tiennent à
leurs vertus gagne si peu et
vieillissent si vite qu'elle ne peuvent
rien n'attendre que la ménopause
s'agissait de toute autre chose ma femme
et mes filles et mon retour dans
l'anxiété
à mon âge je ne peux rien faire que
crever à 14 ans consomme plus ou moins
un à moi que vous m'aidiez à obtenir une
classe comment avez-vous des inscrits
perdre la devise est inscrit là vous
aurez caissier principal de la compagnie
d'assurance contre les risques de
recrutement mon excellent monsieur ma
femme et mes filles vont vous me dire
voilà 60 francs tôt au nom en neige à
c'est inouï c'est inespéré voilà bien
longtemps que l'on n'avait vu que ça va
être la pénombre un petit ruisseau
soyez rassurés je suis déjà dans ma
tombe
on vous en demande pas tant l'interview
est elle de faire la promesse de ne pas
revenir ici avant dix ans un bon mois ni
un mois pour nous vivre à moi avec ses
petits pieds 7
quand des pentes où je ne possède pour
te fortune que ce que vous dites
[Musique]
pour repère mieux le jeu prenait que
vous faisiez quelques petites affaire
d'usure la banque car tu te tapes depuis
la migration des futurs snob vers le
centre les prenne garde et c'est dans le
quartier
pourriez vous avez un cauchemar pour
l'emploi que si j'ai quelques amis
prendrait des actions on excellent
monsieur vous autres faiseurs avait
cassé le grand third enthousiasme on
veut faire ton par l'iddac ce matin
peinant pas non plus adieu camionnette
je vous fais le tram est ce vous saurez
le premier payer vannerie ici un
excellent monsieur ma femme et mes
filles qui ont des prières pour le
mariage de rêve et elvire cadette
monsieur monsieur faire demain est
arrivé je ne peux pas le faire attendre
les autres types très classe n'ont rien
mais en se plaignant comme ça doucement
on arrive à toucher à peu près ses
intérêts combien je regrette mon
dressing du major on veut bien fait et
le 30 mai à justin c'est tout mais cru
en acier était comme celui là moi je
tiendrai pas il m'apporte toujours de
l'argent ce qui lui a parfois des petits
nous tirons de grandes leçons monsieur
nous réside maintenant dans l'amitié
d'un verbe un homme dont la fortune est
mon ouvrage le doigt la reconnaissance
et vous monsieur moi je vous dois de
l'argent
et on se paye ni le nil ou bonjour
mercadé le valent bien plus comme veux
tu as tu as créé par sera ta question
dans le pompeux dorer la pilule ou tu
m'as donné mon vieux mercadé je n'en est
pas et par surcroît je serai franc j'en
aurai que je ne tiendrai pas écoute je
t'ai déjà prêté selon mes moyens me
permettait de disposer
jamais je ne t'ai réclamer ce que tu me
devais je suis ton ami
mais s'il n'avait pas pour toi le coeur
plein de tendresse si j'étais un homme
normal il y a longtemps que le grand ci
aurait assassiné l'ami la compréhension
a ses limites dans ce moment-là mutuashi
limites ou même pas la malchance du coup
si j'étais assez riche pour tous sauté
tout à fait je le ferais d'un grand élan
j'aime ton courage mais c'est écrire tu
dois succomber des dernières tentatives
intelligente certes mais très spécieuse
on croulait tu t'étais considérer que tu
est même devenu un homme dangereux
tu n'as pas su profiter de l'album dont
vous jouissez et la mode très passe là
ou pas une génération voilà quand tu
seras tout à fait tomber sache que non
couverts sera toujours mais chez moi
le devoir d'un ami et de parler ainsi
que je viens de le faire ou serez
l'amitié sur la priver du plaisir de se
trouver sage et de voir son ami fou de
se féliciter d'être soi et d'accuser son
ami de lettres que lui
alors j'ai foutu flétri jambes et fichez
floués
non je ne dis pas tout à fait cela d'
non tu passe encore pour un homme
honnête c'est vous mais la nécessité de
force à recourir à des moyens est tout
simplement ne sont pas justifiées par le
succès le succès il se moquait à grâce à
des subterfuges souvent sorti avec 86g
peut même se met à moi j'ai déterminé la
paix est ce que tu souhaites dans la
sphère des atouts des mythes de la basse
indre a fait plus depuis ce temps à
paris avant que le rapport des
ingénieurs de sorte de lenche supercat
est elle vraie chaumont à mr retenez
bien le nom tout ça pour que tu saches
que j'ai pas besoin de morale ni
caresses
je n'en demande pas pour moi je marie ma
fille mais toute épreuve ici dans une
maison où rennes et l'indigence sous des
apparences de luxe des promesses mon
crédit décidé mon talent tour du sujet
ne bouge d'ici quinze jours de plantes
comme appât 24 ans de mensonges à la
bourse
voilà le marquage moka 80 cette demande
se renouvellera pas tu peux les ma fille
ma ville et ma femme julie faut
aujourd'hui même offrir un dîner à mon
futur gendre j'ai pu d'argentré elle est
là haut tu sais non seulement j'ai
besoin d'un millier de cul mais j'espère
tu prêtera aussi ton service de table
naturellement tout deviendra sous peu
avec ta fort frère cadet où personne n'a
ni vécu à prêter à peine les attentes
ont soir et si on les traitait toujours
on ne les aurait jamais 80 si tu veux
sitôt julie marié ma tome devient
différent
ma femme aura toi chez sa fille j'irai
chercher fortune à gueule on a fait tu
as raison des ardeurs utile aux autres
je me suis funeste à moi même là où je
perds le zoda n'ôte en rien la fée conte
c'est ton esprit est supérieur à ton
jugement l'esprit nouveau la narration
le jugement
nous devons faire la fortune aux nominés
peux-tu concevoir certains sentiments
j'aime les femmes j'aime ma fille elles
sont 6 12 s'y résigner
vous devez les savoirs à l'abri et je
souffre aussi bas que je leur fais peux
tu imaginer que l'or puisque l'eau une
petite fille charmante tu accepterais tu
as quel délice en travaillant des larmes
coulant sur ce joli joue glacé par des
hivers sans fin et tout sens à sa hache
deux tours
voilà pourtant le g7 étant supporté
beaucoup dans la vie j'ai trébuché sur
des thématiques c'est gcrai des
monopoles voilà à tes pieds
nous savons que titi auprès de la
déception de le voir rejeté par tous à
vos amis dans cette circonstance
enfin je te dirai pas ce qu'il va vivre
à 6
une berlinale de voir à tapis
mille écus mais à quoi vous tue dont les
employés ou chez un jean que ta voix off
et effarouchée à côté de moi autour du
cou une robe un peu banal le voilà qui
flanche
et puis vient le dîner il faut des vins
exquis lamoureux ne peut faire de la
tête comme ça tu connais ma fille
s'occupe maintenant un millier d que ça
papa de faire de mal à toi quelque 70
livres de rente et huile 1000 adultes ou
pour enfants que tu es carte il aime
juliette il l avoue le père de les tuer
tu sais qu'elle est folle de ton enfant
majuli rue est elle joue ensemble comme
documente les strates eu la meilleure
amie de ta fille c'est celle sur place
tu sais et c'est contagieux
sa porte mal meerkat et je n'ai pas
mille écus je peux te prêter mon argent
tri mais je n'ai pas mis les gants un
pont sur ta bande à julien tour ce
serait vite fait non tu au tout puissant
pardonnez-moi d'achever racimo
l'existence misérable
permettez moi de me réveiller dans votre
tu trouvé un gendre mon ami un vrai et
gendres tu mets ma parole en doute à
faire de leur refuge voiture par des
moyens naturels pas leurs deux univers
ne force pas on se parlera de l'inde
sait pas par quoi pour mille et culotté
penser tout soit venu à maintenant tu ne
peux être absous comme les blancs je
vais voir si je puis dire ça c'est une
manière de refuser
et si le mariage mans j'ai dit à mon
avis ne vais pas penser cette hypothèse
non non je lui donnerai certainement
mais quand le mariage se fera
il fallait un vécu ne se fera pas sans
toi toi qui j'ai vu dépenses et rafa
puces par mes propres une amourette
comment tu les accorde pas une bonne
oeuvre les bonnes oeuvres comme les
bonnes actions se font rares il peut
nous avions alors la réaction
[Rires]
ces deux copains longtemps roulé leur
bosse ensemble ils ont commencé leur vie
c'est nous mêmes travers tu te rappelles
le beau temps quand tous ces lieux notre
patrie de nous semblait pas bon c'est
pas mal
pas comme ça je rappelle qu'une autre
partie folle à rambouillet en t3
rambouillet qu'est ce qui s'est passé je
vais débattu pour toi contre cet
officier dakar est abaissée de clarisse
était belle et elle était jeune on était
maintenant d'un défi on l'a des filles à
marier sa fille carys 7 ans environ elle
rapprocherait des dictatures si elle
avait vécu je serai toujours célibataire
alors je compte sur vous pour le dîner
et une date à part à l'honneur de
renvoyer donc mon service et les milieux
n'osent lui revient encore je ne peux
pas je suis assassiné mahmoud al arabi
tueur est insensible souvenirs de
clarisse à la bêta du père de julie je
suis sauté histoire et brûler la
cervelle mais servir de l'ocs est permis
tout danger tour de l'ain tu ne rien
dire
je me suis de quoi s'agit-il expliquez
vous je vous prie bernollin je criais la
cour comme deux ans gardien veille sur
l'ours
elle montre au monde battant 10
perdre la vague ratu supprimer toute une
famille cette preuve de trop de respect
tant de courage de trouver votre papa
s'il vous plaît maman c'est moi qui vous
a pleuré pour lui s'il se gérer sans
d'argent je vous offrirai la garantie de
mon travail
obliger une fois encore mon père sa
situation va être cruel pour qu'il
supplie ainsi enfants quelles facs
j'étais pas nature comme ça moi
super de la retenue ce 6e nice nous
serons reconnus je gagerais le bien qui
vous reste ça va pas nous vous savez ils
me demandent mille écus pour pouvoir
vous marier monsieur vers de la oublier
tout ce que je vous ai demandé je ne
veux pas d'un mariage acheté par
l'humiliation de mon père pour que les
visions mais quel épisode aulas
vous m'avez convaincu je vais vous
chercher l'argent me levant le parti a
pas pourquoi vous n'avez vous rien dit
je nous a sauvé à temps que je voudrais
leur premier riches
pourquoi faire de la ce retour de son
geste
je suis pas près de lui pardonner ses
mille écus
oui me libérera
il est allé chercher la somme que vous
avez demandé hallyday a vendu trop cher
quand je pouvais distribuer les billets
dors pas je le faisais avec le grâce à
ses 10 ans prince dorion petit verre de
vin racines d'avancé mille écus mes
scrupules souvent d'un shu selon
soufflerait sans me paraît juste vert de
la cdac des aux accents déchirants de
julie pas au mieux mais ça vous le
reproche
je vais d'agents de voitures pour des
disques et d'attentes j'ai mis le voici
en 3 5 vous avez désormais aux copains
reconnaissance ça ne vous fera jamais de
vous madame il faut que les choses
soient claires c'est à vous et à votre
fille que je prête cet argent vous aurez
l'obligeance de contre signer le reçu
que vam établir mercadé cinéma pertes et
toi je vis comme on vient voir demain
faut-il ajouter les intérêts non non on
oublie on les intérêts oubliant lieu où
je vais vous aider mon père lui juriez
bâti voilà ton seconde est monsieur
ménard demande aides reçues
madame les livres apporte toutes les
marchandises delà du bac il était tant
rêver au mercy mercy mercy bon je vous
laisse
bonne chance à tous si j'ai bien compris
mina s'est de prominent a rien compris
c'est un adolf
si vous voulez nous comment tu reçu
dûment payé autant de courage que j'en
ai montré déjà mais que c'est une passe
et un fils à papa se présenter monsieur
mercadet sans pitié pour nous je
triompherez
vous aimez maffini musiciens oui
monsieur et moi elle accroît la même une
talent de nos persuader le doute que
vous exprimez monsieur venant de l'autre
que vous mmes en france très gravement
mais comme on n'aimerait pas julie vente
aux filles une seule lettre au monde qui
m'est fait connaître l'affection julie
monsieur mai mais c'est une soeur une
cousine et une amie un seul et toute ma
famille aussi n'ai pas de mot qui puisse
vous traduire la passion que j'éprouve
pour elle on est gourmand
le séminaire
j'ai sur l'amour entre jeunes gens les
idées positives qu'on reproche
généralement aux vieillards mais ma
méfiance d'autant qu'il est juste que je
ne suis pas de ses pairs aveuglés par la
paternité pas être tout à fait les julie
ne possède pas cette beauté caractère
non ou mal et libyen nie pas à vous vous
trompez monsieur vous vous le connaissez
pas votre jugement mais parfaitement
comme si je l'avais fait - ah non
monsieur j'insiste vous connaissez la
jolie que chacun voit et koné mais
l'amour la transfigure latendresse lui
communique un charme à bissau que mois
sacré mais vous me flattez je me croyais
son père et voilà le père de julie avec
laquelle il me plairait de faire
connaissance
alors ouvrez les yeux minard les
qualités de son un peu je le conçois
modifier l'expression de sa physionomie
mais le teint mineurs jubilé modeste
elle est aussi lucide elle c'est elle
c'est qu'elle a le teint moussa et les
traits un peu disgracieux papa vous
n'avez donc pas aimer beaucoup au
contraire comme tous les hommes
autrefois vous aimiez une femme pour sa
séduction
aujourd'hui nous aimons beaucoup mieux
oui nous nous attachons alors et c'est
ce qui rend ma fille jolie par honnête
le phare à des lourdeurs dans la tronche
l'âme les efface la méfient les doigts
ôta coquetterie dans leur langue fait de
belles poitrines petits pieds là mais
toujours présente pour chasser le
mauvais salaires inavoué mais julie elle
est aimable la d'esprit du coeur de
l'âme vous les laisse au final arrière
pensée aucune à voter vos rêves le reste
de vos mii vous la voulez pour femmes
oui monsieur
malgré tous les obstacles je suis venu
pour les femmes ayhan de vous
découragera rien il m'aime comme je la
machette pare-feu ou sochaux pour un pic
de voir sa fille québécois elle le
mérite elle mentionne ces bonhommes de
son choix est maintenant suivie vers
nous rejointe un moment le séminaire et
moi nous avons à parler de façon plus
concrète
oui à puissance dans l'idéal ça n'a
malheureusement aucune influence sur les
rentes
comme vous voudrez pas seul nous allons
parler france
monsieur vous n'aimez pas ma fille dit
monsieur que vous avez enlevé un riche
parti pour julie que vous ne voulez pas
tenir compte de ces accusations et je
vous comprendrez mais sachez le monsieur
je me suis venu vous demander sa main
après avoir obtenu son cas son père son
km mais ça y est deux semaines à genève
et respectueusement si cela va vous
appeler ça m'apaise adolphe et vous
confier mon secret mauges amis je suis
sans ressources en ruine et totalement
ruiné je vous laisse julie elle sera
mieux chez vous citez milliers que vous
soyez que dans ma maison
elle est 100 tonnes
je veux dire elle est hot et de parents
aux
elhadji qui fait faire il n'y a rien au
delà reçu des amendes est énormément de
tête d'al qaîda
je suis jeune j'ai l'avenir devant
revoir jeu je possède de l'énergie oui
je suis assez ambitieux j'arriverai je
me sens capable d'enrichir celle que
chaque personne soit je me suis arrivé
pour madame mercadé nous avons conservé
ses habitudes opulence moi aussi je
sacrifiais l'idéal jadis et les
créanciers dans la fantaisie 6 pas mal
du bowler convaincu aucune pensée
d'intérêt n'entache mon amour requis la
vieuville happytime vous avez prononcé
cette phrase à merveille petites ut
mineur
vous aimez assez jolie pour acheter très
cher la joie de l'épouser mais que
peut-on donner de plus que sa vie un
amour si profondément sincère sera
récompensé enfin elle totale confiance
je la mérite monsieur rené mongeau
voici quelques papiers de famille qui
attesteront d'autres fortunes le nom de
nous je ne suis pas indiscret je vous en
prie nouvelle gamme et fortune tout mais
dati de l'elysée mais si la copie du
procès verbal de la saisie de notre
mobilier
là vous trouverez des commandements en
masse c'est dans cette dérive et une
signification de contraintes hardcore
faîtière ça devient sérieux regagné 1
comme le jugement mais protêt voilà tous
les dossiers sont classés
il faut avoir de l'ordre quand on vit
dans le désert un désordre des
l'organisons sur true blood a mis tout
homme est flatté de voir sa dette
inscrite à son union à l'heure je me
suis modelé sur notre ministre des
finances mais remboursement comme son
budget suive lente alphabétique et lui
comme moi n'avons pas encore entamé la
lettre à n'avaient rien payé au total
380 mille fois oui c'est exact la
récapitulation et la lui vous reviendrez
pas un père ravis de se débarrasser de
sa fille aurait cherché à vous tromper
il aurait promis le dot imaginaire
adhérents est fabuleuse ne sèche ont
fait de cette tournée
et si vous traitez avec un homme spécial
mentorat ménard vous n'êtes plus
intelligent qu'il n'y paraît tu ne
voudrais pas une vie pour ta cantona que
tous en francs l'appointement s'est
marié la saisie avec le problème
vous croyez monsieur ainsi à si vous
vous pensez que je pourrait nuire à
julie mineurs julia maintenance au fret
messieurs j appelle à des bonus qui
d'ailleurs sont pourris dehors ont
plaisait à manquer avec un aplomb super
khadr pour quel point le ministre
l'assemblée kaboul la clameur et part
dieu vous seriez clumeq à des jeux
puissent accepter au sarc avril à las
palmas que le plein vous avez trouvé
l'appelle ma famille vous avez mis dans
la tête expliqué cité fo serait très
affecté par votre faute vous avez fait
mach pour préparer le repas
morandé lunel que gilles vous avec huit
aujourd'hui main et vous mettrez à la
mariée au mais monsieur qu'est ce que
vous me demandez si vous les laissez
vous oui alors secondes et moi s'agit
pour elle d'avoir une fortune à l'eau et
vous pourrez restés ostensiblement et
kouider où y'a rien de déshonorant je
veux leur d'allaman qui se sacrifie en
france chacun désire tout de suite ce
que tout le monde n'a pas l'envié est au
fond du coeur humain comme une vipère 11
autres
l'incompris n'ajouterai plus rien quant
à julie g libellé vous prévenez je vous
laisse ce soin tu l'a préparé à ce
changement
moi elle m'a accusé de mentir si je lui
disais que vaut renoncer
je vous laisse
adolphe alors mademoiselle noizet je ne
suis plus julie avait tout réglé avec
mon père oui enfin c'est à dire votre
père a des raisons judiciaires
excusez le lapsus je voulais dire
judicieux à dole vous m'aimez plus j'ai
toujours très fort j'avais le coeur cir
est déjà nommée julie ans julie la
situation de monsieur mercader très
mauvaise elle nous vous à la misère il
ya des hommes qui la misère comme de
l'énergie et bien moi oui mouais el baba
j'aurais du courage pour deux vous
verrez toujours mon sourire pour le
stimuler
je ne serai pas à charge pas sur
porcelaine je gagnerai presqu'autant
vous notre appartement sera un véritable
palais je ne vous ai jamais vu si belle
mais mais adolphe métal adverbe sur moi
c'est oui ou c'est non
peut-être ce qu'on souhaite à la rigueur
alors que oui mais est une formule de
caloto monsieur mercadier a fait appel à
la délicatesse il m'a prouvé combien
d'amour était une passion rigoriste
nommé chili il ya deux manières d'aimer
l'amour qui vous livrent à la misère est
extravagant mais l'amour qui se
sacrifient à votre bonheur et héroïque
mon seul bonheur a donc fait d'être
votre votre père m'a demandé de renoncer
à vous vous avez renoncé j'essaie je le
voudrais et mystérieusement je le puis
il ya quelque chose au fond de moi qui
me répète que je ne serai jamais plus
aimés comme je le suis pas certain
mon amour ne servant pas y vivent encore
par l'orage encore
je ne puis accepter quand vous demandons
de l'oublier et bien adieu à dole à dieu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma veuillez padma cruauté je perds à vif
mais c'est pour votre bien un jour le
remercie je suis ya pire
mes illusions sans vent adolphe ne
m'aimait pas et la terre continue de
tourner
n'est ce pas
je suis résigné je serai madame de la
briche pour sauver je me retrouve jeu
bretagne puis je lis votre société et
heureusement divisé où l'eau est on à
dos la hâte des premiers m'enchante sont
fait partie soyez-en menons ensemble
grande pompe ans lors vous confère à
tout et grâce se révèle ce fait devenir
riche
donnez moi la main les prépare aux
ensembles autre succès moi je savoure
déjà ma revanche
eux ils vont pleurer tous ces drogues la
guitare et on soit va détruire
bon courage monsieur la banque la bourse
et du bluff berkanais forge une nouvelle
philosophie d affaires par l'otan ce qui
est partout moi je reprends les classes
lui mais la magnificence ya chez nous
[Applaudissements]
je vous ai vu entrer me voici aussitôt
je suis sans fierté et moi sans force
vous ne m'aimez pas autant que je vous
ai madoff si seulement vous aviez du
regret j'ai ferait manquer ces mariages
et mieux sans que mon perçue par quels
moyens les quatre viendrait-il après
nous aurions l'avenir pour nous les
chances de notre avenir sont nuls
comment pouvez vous parler ainsi écouter
- julie je me sens coupable en vient
j'en éprouve une peine immense et c'est
pourquoi je je me crois digne d'être
pardonné
vous m'avez cru pupilles mais je vais
être sincère j'espérais que votre
fortune serait le tremplin qui me
permettrait de vous offrir la situation
dont je rêvais pour n'hésite pas à moi
de plus je vous pardonne vos ambitions
vos calculs je suis sûr maintenant que
vous m'aimez je ferais manquer ce
mariage j'ai dans le crâne une petite
vente et et qui répète sans cesse qui
sera heureuse tu seras heureux j'avais
trop peur se fâche silva est ainsi
occupée à coup c'est surtout avec
monsieur ménard
allez vous appuyez messieurs de la
priver de mairie qui pourrait vous
surprendre
non c'est tenue négligent madame ma
visite n'est pas indiscret
je viens rendre ses lettres à
mademoiselle et lui redemande et les
miennes selon le désir de monsieur
mercadet maintenant vous savez
maintenant que nous nous aimons les
frais vous demande rien pour votre fille
on se situe à se retrouver en besoin
d'un gendre qu'il lui soit utile
qui le seconde dans ces opérations il
est condamné ces mariages échoue et moi
navire acté définitivement raté du
vannes oc un caissier de messieurs
mercatech ekotto s'il ya des créanciers
le monsieur merkel oui madame et je
viens de parler des problèmes de
monsieur mercader peut certes ils les
connaissaient déjà madame
cependant il ne les trouve pas un saut
lui je peux le convaincre de se charger
de la liquidation
mon mari liquide yves mais vous
plaisantez
mes semblables aux joueurs un crochet la
table se décident son destin fasciné par
les cartes espérons toujours tirer un
carré d'as je ne sais vraiment pas
jusqu'où il serait capable d'aller pour
conserver le droit de faire fortune lui
liquide y renoncer aux affaires mais
c'est sa vie monsieur vous ne ferez pas
revenir sur sa décision
et puis je le blâmer comme épouse comme
maire d'avoir su prendre le partie de la
fortune au genou aussi proche de la
misère
si ces mamans vous me faites mal
messieurs de la brive et de méricourt
souhaité attendre ici je vais demander à
monsieur verkade et de les recevoir pour
allonger me allons changer d'europe
suivez-moi adolphe je vais vous rendre
vos lettres entre monsieur ces dames
sont encore devant leur miroir et pris
ces messieurs de bien vouloir attendre
un moment monsieur mercadet vient tout
de suite
enfin mon cher te voilà dans la place
bientôt tu sera officiellement fiancée à
julie mercader attention conduit bien à
barres que le papa est un finaux oui
c'est ce qui m'effraie il sera difficile
de tromper
moi je ne crois pas mais arcade est un
spéculateur aujourd'hui dans les ans il
peut se retrouver misérable demain et
what if
je pense qu'il est enchanté de mettre
une partie de sa fortune sous le nom de
sa fille
par surcroît un gendre la capables de
l'épauler n'est pas pour lui déplaire
non mais moi j'ai confiance et s'ils
voulaient prendre un peu trop de
renseignements j'en ai donné
d'excellents à madame mercato une femme
de 40 ans estime que tout ce que lui dit
son amant est forcément vrai ce qui
m'arrive est trop beau à peine crédible
enfin tu perds ton appelant lors bien
sûr d'apposition est au plus bas réponse
je conçois qu'il peut être à bout de
souffle pour se marier
c'est un suicide pour don juan
mais voyons peux-tu tenir encore à
condition d'aller vite en besogne
je m'appelle michelin pour les huissiers
tailleur se refuse de gouges à
comprendre mon avenir mon cheval vit à
crédit ce qui est gentil de sa part
quant à ce malheureux de la bri je ne
sais comment ils respirent ni où il se
nourrit jeunes osent pénétrer ce mystère
mais les cours ne sommes nous pas assez
avancée en civilisation pour qu'on fasse
une loi qui supprimerait toutes les
dettes à chaque 1er de l'an
un bon vieil à l'aministie l'aministie
c'est l'invention comme des magic d'un
homme d'état de génie elle permet sur
simple décret de tirer du puits les bons
qui ont mal tourné
les crapules qui se sont fait des
relations le contribuable qui se
refusait à contribuer et l'ennemi
politique quand il a cessé d'être
dangereux elle rend sympathique lé
magnanimité elle est populaire c'est
pourquoi l'amnistié vient toujours un
oui en attendant je dois payer aux payé
de ma personne c'est mon seul capital
oui hein je les vois d'ici non mais gère
des salons à la mode quoi vous avez vu
ce petit de la brime ce garçon très coté
dans le monde assez heureux au jeu de
visage agréable et qui n'a pas 30 ans eh
ben ils se marient à la fille d'un
spéculateur l'aide ai dit tu entres
système est c'est un peu démoralisant
mais une oisiveté menace il faut
travailler notre malheur à nous autres
les aristocrates ces deux sentira
peut-être tout est de n'être en
définitive bon à rien la société n'a pas
créé d'emplois pour les basses et
entendu je ferai des affaires avec
mercadet c'est un de nos grands faiseurs
nous remueront à nous de le monde du
commerce
tu es certain - qui ne peut pas alloué à
sa fille - deux cent cinquante mille
francs mais tu es aveugle
enfin regarde autour de toi tout respire
l'opulence ici et tout est luxe mais ça
promet on a hâte eu la possibilité de
tangage et j'ai gagné hier au club de
quoi faire les choses très bien pour la
corvée du mariage je donnerai un peu je
devrais - mise à part à combien se monte
dans une bagatelle 150 mille francs
comme mon beau père fera réduire à 50
milles par conséquence il me restera 100
milles c'est bien suffisant pour lancer
un premier marché j'aurai toujours dit
c'est quand je l'aurai plus souple dit
avery choix mercader questionnera c'est
un matois es-tu prêt à lui répondre je
peux c'est de la terre de la bri 3000 à
rependre les langues qui vaut 30 mille
francs
il peut être quarante cinq mille et dès
qu'on peut mettre en action pour
l'extraction de n'importe quoi aux
chiffres de cent mille écus méricourt tu
ne peux pas te faire une idée de ce
qu'elle m'a déjà rapporté cette terre
oui mais ta terre ton nom et ton cheval
sont à 2
as you tu es décidé je veux être un
homme politique il faut une femme pour
ça l'aide de préférence ça émeut le
peuple alors tu es assez adroit pour cet
office pour vous appeler au partage du
pouvoir on ne vous demande pas
aujourd'hui ce que vous pouvez faire de
bien mais ce que vous pouvez faire de
mal il s'agit pas d'avoir des capacités
et d'inspirer la crainte on n'est pas
très vaillant en politique on ne peut
pas blanchir tous ces tas de linge sale
alors on se méfie on fait le dos rond on
fait échange de scandales donne walbert
je te passe un fromage je connais
parfaitement notre époque
tiens en dînant en jouant en faisant des
dons les deux vêtements je faisais mon
cours de droit politique
ouais mais là demain bord tu n'as que le
jargon de la réclame ou du racolage mais
il y faut aussi un peu de savoir mon ami
dans tous les métiers on a dans les
sciences dans la littérature
il faut une mise de fonds ou des
connaissances savantissime ou des dons
particuliers ou simplement du talent il
faut prouver nécessairement alors qu'en
politique on a tous et on est tous avec
trois ou quatre mots à lesquels les
principes de mes amis l'opinion à
laquelle j'appartiens la ligne de
conduite du parc
alors ça enfin mon cher mari qu il vaut
mieux être bête comme tout le monde tu
es intelligent comme personne au sein
monsieur est sans doute monsieur l'abri
oui monsieur qu'est ce que c'est que ça
c'est le petit imbécile qui fait la cour
à l'héritière à l'héritage
oui et qu'on a refusé pour toi êtes
heureux monsieur vous avez les
privilèges de la forte une jeune fille
vous plaît vous l'épouser permettez moi
de croire monsieur que sans aucune
fortune j'aurai encore quelques chances
personnelles
un monsieur si je possédais le quart de
la moitié de ce que vous avez je le
savais à personne ce trésor de grâce et
de perfection vous avez pour vous
l'autorité de monsieur mercader et vous
monsieur moi monsieur je n'ai que mon
amour pour lui
monsieur je voudrais vous être utile
cela m'est impossible je souhaiterais
vous être agréable
je ne le puits hélas monsieur puisque le
hasard fait que nous regroupons je me
sens la force de dire monsieur rendez-la
richier bonjour aux amériques où vous
avez lu ma femme n'aura à ces dames ne
font bien languirand toutes les bêtes
dès qu'il s'agit de leurs toilettes un
tremblement de terre nous envieraient au
ciel sautez sur la ps3
le féminin je vous croyais impact
nous nous sommes j'imagine assez
nettement expliqué partout mais cela
passe on justifie bien des actes de foi
il est certaine délicatesse qu'il ne se
double ipa jeu je vous comprends très
bien monsieur mais il n'est pas douteux
pour y être un peu plus accablé adieu
monsieur vilar salle au moins un soupir
adieu messieurs soyez indulgent pour un
homme qui perd sa raison de vivre
juste au moment où la vie allait lui
donner raison d'être n'est pour cette
raison là bas ça j'ai fait sur phase
arrêtée à dieu mais c'est bien mineure
oa minarro fond je le plains tu adores
julie mais que voulez-vous il n'a pas de
10000 livres d'enfants on ne va pas bien
loin avec cela on végète et pourtant il
y avait bien flairé ce que vaut une et
comme il est très réussi il avait mis ma
femme de son côté faussement j'élève
j'étais jouer la manoeuvre un homme qui
connaît la musique table c'est à brive
en intriguant la faire craquer vous ne
pouviez accorder la main de votre fille
au premier venu seul en ne perdant pas
tant ces tables rondes ou rejoint par
lens home surnomme dans what au but
aimez-vous jules et passionnément un peu
trop pour être heureux en ménage dans
mercadé j'interviens voilà mon ami de la
bri la adore la musique alors la voie du
sully son timbre chaud son étendue sa
souplesse enfin temps de qualité lente
et blue hill monsieur des gens atteints
de ma fille et où son nom m'échappe
lâché un beau qui en ces représentants
de l'esprit de votre fille me ravit
monsieur je crois la loi décroître
atteint 6 mois je vais la bourse ma
fille déploie ses ailes et traverse à
new york
elle est tout ordre elle est toute
poésie vous êtes de l'école romantique
non monsieur on le peut aimer julie sur
le cultive pas certains l'idée est là
explique toi monsieur je suis ambitieux
ça c'est mieux oui j'ai reconnu ma
demoiselle votre fille en est trop
délicat plein d'esprit doué de beaucoup
de charme j'ai pensé que sa présence ne
s'est jamais déplacé en quelques lieux
que je me trouve ceci est capitale pour
la réussite d'un homme politique
raisonnement à thé cape une femme en
effet saleté comme toujours ici qui veut
être ministre ambassadeur de france
rencontre n'ayant pas peur des baux sa
femelle
monsieur vous êtes l'avenir de la france
naturellement je suis socialiste
et moi je suis capitaliste
embrassons-nous le fond d'euro le
socialisme du capitalisme
bonjour existons nous partagerons le
monde des finances et ceux ci leur avait
peut-être moi vous dire des cieux
parlant de intérêts oui mais semble que
cela regarde vos noté monsieur raison
cela nous regarde bien davantage je suis
un réseau aussi monsieur je possède pour
toute fortune la terre de la bri elle
est dans ma famille depuis 150 ans et
n'en sortira jamais j'espère que ça me
tracasse aujourd'hui il est préférable
de posséder deux pics à pitre aux les
capitaux on les assume
chez les cas qu'une révolution il sait
pas tout avec vous et vous suivent pas
la terre au contraire car on sait qu'à
la paye pour tout le monde
elle reste comme soft se basant portera
pas grave je ne suis pas mauvais diable
cette terre quelle est son importance
3000 arpents sens entre la rechange
éclats de voix le déshabiller un jeu un
chaton pu démarrer sa non qu'on pourrait
exploiter dès que l'administration des
livres à son autorisation et si je
deviens ministre ça ne traînera pas nous
serons alors assuré de produits zeller
mais pourquoi me plaît nous sommes dues
comme du site à cette terre par
conséquent est au bord de la mer mind
milieu oui oui si tu es ou nommés
directement et à près de bordeaux c'est
épatant de terrain à bordeaux
certains gosses c'est l'américaine en
dollars au début nous n'ont heureusement
nous la vigne suppose trop de frais le
vin se vend mal non mater exige peu
d'entretien elle fait planter enfin par
mon grand-père anatole de la bri louis
qui eu l'esprit de se sacrifier pour sa
postérité
ah j'oubliais ricochet le mobilier le
mobilier que vous connaissez ah oui
l'automobile et pot de terre vont barrer
je vois je vois le parti qu'on peut
tirer de ces bars et là nous fonderons
une société en commandite pour
l'exploitation des bars et salons de la
brume salom ya tout à millions amassés
je le sais bien monsieur il reste à se
les faire offrir
bon autre chose avez-vous des têtes
le menu auto partage cette terre et tôle
hypothéquer aaa
on peut vous aider officiellement un
domaine dont la propriété appartient
secrètement as bien aussi les offres
mercadet voyons vous l'estimez riez pas
mon ami s'il ne devait pas quelque
argent
monsieur je serai franc il y as pour
45000 d'hypothèque sur la terre de la
bri
je vous sais mon jambes vous êtes
l'époux de mouchoirs vous le connaissez
pas votre fortune ça va trop bien il
avait une spéculation et facilement
réaliser ce que j'attendais d'un genre
prenez pas l'esprit pescade le
propriétaire de province le nous
entendons monsieur vous ne vous vexez
pas si de mon côté je me renseigne avant
ma fille recevra de la part de sa mère
une petite ferme qu'il a que 200 arpents
mais si tu es en brie et bien battre un
mois je lui laisse de sa mère rom dont
je me servirai la rente jusqu'à ce que
vous ayez trouvé un bon placement ne
nous abusons pas de la bribe de
remplacer des affaires je vous sais pas
vous plaisait beaucoup deluxe vous
désirez brillé à paris joue un grand
rôle
n'est ce pas de la bri et oui monsieur
plage c'est évident et ça connais les
hommes
les jauges les juges je les souplesses
aller de la tenue
nous appelons la branche moi même je
suis vieux déjà bon ça fait rien
l'heure a sonné de reporter vos
ambitions sur un autre mois mais à
monsieur j'aurais eu à choisir entre
tous les bons pères de paris c'est à
vous à qui j'aurais donné la préférence
vous êtes fait ce nom que sa mort est
mon ami n'ose vous l'avouer mais l'offre
il est rapide et hommes pour vous le
cacher il a aussi d'autres petites
dettes
vous pouvez parler monsieur je comprends
parfaitement ces choses là
voyons ce émissaire sacre à piles france
inter oui c'est cela va peu à peu près
comme nous l'espérons en action des bars
et salles hadba frise qu'est ce que
c'est une peccadille sec le plus franc
nous évaluerons les temps cent mille
francs de plus près tout je suis je suis
sauvé souris body madame permettez moi
de vous présenter monsieur de la bri il
est de mes amis le mauvais et il ressent
pour votre fille une admiration
passionnés sound aka je le devine vous
prisé les espagnols eux barrymore
regardez moi ce teint n'est pas une
véritable andalouse à la clé femme brune
pour résister aux tempêtes de l'oeuf
j'aurais cru à une blonde
monsieur ma fille est tout à fait la
femme qui convient à un homme politique
et les muets souris banlieue
parfaitement moulée admirablement
habillée telle mère telle fille
au sous sol madame je place tous mes
espoirs sous votre protection loisel
j'ose espérer que vous vous opposez
paramé veut obéir à mon père cela fait
deux mois que j'attends avec serveur le
bonheur de vous présenter mes hommes
je suis flatté monsieur d'avoir pu
attirer votre attention et les traits
pliable les costumes à la météo est de
savoir si je puis être heureuse en
épousant ce monsieur ce cadeau du ciel
vous va comme un gant
ces messieurs ne faut bien le plaisir
d'accepter a dit n'est censé répondre à
la fortune du pauvre le parc de la brée
boussois de change vous le promets si la
mairie que voulez vous me donnez votre
avis sur un tableau que nous venons de
nous allons vous laisser causer avec
votre fiancée merci à l'écran manège
tout comme toutes les jeunes filles
prend les avec elle les chemins de la
police ni le cachons l'action sous la
phrase j'ai compris je serai romanesque
heures il est vraiment très fort très
fort soré bon nul
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur ne trouvez pas étrange que je
vous demande des preuves de votre amour
subi ma méfiance mais commandé par la
connaissance que j'ai des monts peu
d'attrait cette modestie et déjà un
attrait mademoiselle si j'avais cette
beauté miraculeuse qui suscite des
passions soudaine jeu trouvera des
motifs à votre recherche
mais pour mai mais il faut connaître mon
coeur et nous nous voyons pour la
première fois moise l île et des
courants irrépressible vous ne savez pas
pourquoi mon aimé le jour qu'on se
l'expliquent l'amour existe-t-il non la
première fois que je vous ai vu et
comment cela fait deux mois que je vous
aime je vous ai entendu au dernier
concert de monsieur verdon ouverte là où
il votre voix m'a révélé tout une
sensibilité une crèche d'auchan je me
souviens que de l'impression mais qui
punit les femmes
ainsi vous aimeriez nous arrêterait rien
j'aime à nos garçons monsieur oui je les
ai aperçus je vous l'avouer il m'a déçu
votre jugement m'a donné des inquiétudes
il n'est pas votre fête du tout mais je
ne puis renoncé à lui qu en faveur d'un
grand sacrifice mon père m'a dit que
vous étiez prêts à l'aider dans ses
affaires sous cette condition je dirais
cet amour que je souhaitais éternelle je
serai une épouse fidèle et aimante cessé
de mettre ma passion sincère à l'épreuve
et sachez que monsieur mercadé moi nous
nous sommes entendus sur les questions
d'intérêt
il vous a tout dit tout vous le savez
ruiner
comment ça ruine et on me doit environ
310 francs
il doit 3
vous n'aimez pas vous êtes très forte
quand bien même votre paire de valets
millions je vous épouserais toujours car
je vous l avoue jouer très bien la
comédie je m'en félicite
vous serez une ambassadrice prodigieuse
monsieur pierre 15 désire parler à
monsieur votre père à propos de monsieur
de la bri je crois exposition pierre cas
dans cette maison décidément c'est mon
jour de guigne mademoiselle je suis
votre obligé mais c'est mon mich un
homme à paroles
à l'origine je vois que vous ètes du
complot que l'organisation qui est mi
chemin des victoires introuvable ne
lâchez pas alerté la police pour arrêter
monsieur de la brive michaud n'a pour
nous si vous permettez
il est paris s'agit pied de pézan qu'à
ses meubles sous le nom d'un ami
[Musique]
vous nous racontez là l'histoire la plus
drôle de toute l'histoire des histoires
amusé le je vous en supplie une fois que
ferais je garde ce cadre là se fera
délivrer par quelques dames en mal
d'aventuré à la supercar et vous prie de
l'excuser monsieur il est occupé par le
mariage de mademoiselle tchad aurait
avec qui mais avec ce monsieur
ah non c'est pas vrai mais ce serait
trop beau a passé s'est marié deux
faillites ensemble on va rire la course
comme jamais un si court
ou nommé vous michonne monsieur de la
brive
oui mademoiselle c'est notre nom de
famille pierre quality la vérité
lorsqu'il prétend que vous avez des
dettes ou très peu et je les ai déclaré
à votre père ainsi vous maîtrisez par
amour et pour ma date
mais vous trouverez en moins le plus
tendre des maris je vous laisserai
maîtresse de votre fortune et puis là
brive existe c'est un charmant petit
village où je possède une terre oui j'ai
fait comme beaucoup d'autres j'ai pris
le nom du village et depuis 10 ans je me
nomme de la bri hélas ce monsieur
moi aussi je suis sans facture julie
voilà vous même vous accusation pour cet
affreux minard et vous pousse à
calomnier votre père a éclairé monsieur
michaud qui ne peut épouser une fille
sans argent moi je me tue tout bon jeu
s'appelle bissonnet me shawn heins de
labriffe
julie lescaut
pierre qui est parti pour faire
emprisonner monsieur j'espère que vous
ne le permettrait pas je ne devrais pas
avoir joué à villars au qatar on
n'arrête plus quand le soleil est couché
d'ailleurs j'avais serait pire qu'un a
vu monsieur annonce est un mirage je
suis bien plus qu'aux socialistes je
deviens communiste pu tromper comme à la
course et par méricourt l'album ma femme
a three suffit d'une seule attitude est
un sage la blague je ne vous ai pas
caché mais d'être soi on peut demander
d'être dégoûté un heureux pour femme
austère dans les landes
ça consiste en quoi en sable plantes et
de sapins
de quoi faire des cure-dents peu près ça
vaut 30 me c'est hypothéquer 2 45 me
vous avez su ce talent là mon dieu oui
en [ __ ] c'est pas bête du tout court
il vaut fameux marais touche la mer
c'est l'os est en cours il sabrié tenue
ça les gens de ce pays sont de méchantes
langues mais en place sont stoppés net
il était difficile de mettre la mer en
actions si vous me passez l'expression
ça n'est pas la mer à boire
non mais à faire avaler
qui te motive votre moralité me paraît
assez contestable vous signez d'après
certains dossiers que je possède votre
est oui stoner et vous vous faites à
pédales
avant je pourrais vous assaisonnez
durement à des piments nous n'avancions
cieux n'allez pas trop loin et veut tout
et vous voyez la fin de ce subterfuge de
passer sur habitante pénétrer au sein
d'une famille respectable abusé sa
confiance pis vous avez faim tu aimé ma
fut monsieur nuggets ne dit pas le mot
il vous coûtera la vie
je vous êtes mon hôte du calme je me
sens après julie est elle une dot
non non aviez-vous 200 mille fois votre
silence parle non vous n'aviez pas de
cent mille francs et moi j'engage est ma
liberté vous cherchez sastre aucun jeu
on ne ferme et fort méritée vous avez
affronté sur des simples le solde soit
sa course au dessus de la valeur ne fait
pousse par une volée avec du sable ont
fait du cristal
mais ces unités semble et bien que nous
ressemblons moralité sont identiques tu
veux te rappeler ce que je peux vous
aplatir
hier tabasser des pour tarentini fraude
retraite fraises et intérêts vous ferez
coffret pendant cinq ans alors là
monsieur je serai votre onze ans de
prépa surtout la boutique de 1 messieurs
cambrai alors vous vous moquez ton de
votre signature
pas vous désormais vous crâne et à votre
situation est quasi désespérée mairie
comme marie parce que je lui dois 30
mille francs
je ne vous ferai pas un cours de théo
tholot non je préférerais un billet demi
moi aussi allons oublier tous soyez mont
poupet n'a eu de misère ferait une trop
grande pauvreté
vous allez écouter vous ceci dit d'où
certainement dans les circonstances
dramatiques dit les portes conseil des
balades à la connaissance profonde de
l'homme j'ai l'habitude mon désespoir
des noms je viens d'apercevoir la
voiture devient dès lors qu'elles
peuvent pour que la fête soit complète
tech début du mois je n'amène pas mal à
me faire de la junior même si je peux
dire avec toi tu es sur bèze amène la
phase aller
qu'est-ce qui va pas mon vieux et scrat
engendre s class hop au mariage là se
maria ne se fera pas je suis trompé par
méricourt méricourt tu sais c'est qu'il
nous ait méfie groupe nos pieds mais les
gars pas deux mais ce matin tu va servir
de cette comédie avec distribution de
personnages à ta femme est à tapis pour
m'arracher mille écus je m'en doutais et
je me suis pris dans son filet mercadé
tuer la chef à jo sans que tu vas me
faire de la perds tu as tu n'as tu te
l'on comprend pas la tête plus su tu
veux soupçonne tu me juge ou moins
fléchi pub résonne un peu pourquoi
torrejon emprunté trop service de table
pourquoi aurais-je habiller les femmes
ça 9
si j'avais pas cru un seul marc a manqué
qu'il mondory tu as ton portefeuille
plein de créances sur mon ordre et ça le
fait rire quelqu'un m'a dit que techland
qui se réunissait ce soir jégou là pour
agir comme un seul homme
on veut débarrasser la bourse autocool
pourra de tous les feux sera fait mais a
déçu alors demain on m'apparaît en
prison dans un fiacre le corbillard du
spéculateur
mais quelle horreur allez viens du démon
gros ce dilemme coûte trop cher il
passerait pas respecté la deûle un
demain à la bourse reconnaîtra bertagnol
ces belles de la firme solennellement
toute bête est seront remboursés le tout
la maison-mère cas des malaxeurs à deux
millions je serai le napoléon des
affaires et s'en va t en ou tulle tonnes
de fer qui peut te répondre à un
négociant qui vous dit messieurs passer
à la caisse je dîne après toujours au
moins récupérer ça
yves albert kahn et du steak nature en
imperatore damage trône sur des millions
ou alors je me couche dans les trois
unités de la scène
ils sont passés à table méricourt cool
des regards langoureuse à madame
mercadet sa chaussure épices ou la table
la poutine compréhensive thérèse ses
relais order verdun raconte des
histoires l'est
il rit beaucoup tout seul parfois mercat
des limites par complaisance thérèse
sert le rôti de labriffe et le pot pour
gagner sa sucette julie fixe le lustre
les yeux vides
thérèse sert le fromage de la bride
refait le monde vers de la refait le
monde mercadé refait le monde mais c'est
toujours le même c'est leur monde
thérèse sert le gâteau de fiançailles le
vin fait monter les enchères cet acteur
ajoutera pour mieux briller moi moi moi
ce ne sera donc jamais nous thérèse sur
le café les alcools les liqueurs vite
très vite plus vite
inexorablement le temps égrène son
chapelet de grains de minutes on se
congratule on se sépare la nuit vient
majestueusement suivi de son cortège de
l'est bulleuse sous ses ailes
recouvertes dhombres se trame de
nouvelles harmonies peu à peu le jour se
dépouillent de ces cocons de rosé il a
percé les mille et un ventre des
ténèbres
puis s'il sera encore comme toujours le
témoin impavide du combat de l'homme
contre l'homme
il faut que la ville de mossoul goutte
d'eau soient tenues secrètes c'est
essentiel alors monsieur vous êtes cuit
monsieur prédit fait déjà sorti le
tapage que cette berline a fait cette
nuit
en entendant la cour à deux heures du
matin à réveiller toute la maison
monsieur brédif le premier à sassenay
qui a cru d'abord que monsieur partait
pour bruce alonso je paye monsieur
devient fou
tu te crois déjà mon secrétaire ta part
d'autres justement tu me comprends
monsieur cette berline est savamment
crottés seulement le père drumeaux a
observé qu'elle n'apportait pas de
bagages godomey une telle aux atouts de
réparer ses torts envers voit qu'il a
oublié ses colis aux as
il arrive de calcutta son bateau
transporte une cargaison d'une abondance
inaccoutumée et sa femme est restée là
bas tu sais qu'il a fini par est plus
est la mère de son fils cyril valles les
fortes heureux que monsieur ait passé la
nuit à travailler à l'ordinaire monsieur
veille rarement si tard ainsi la plus
grosse banque oddo pourra placer vous
avez fait ripaille monsieur justin vous
êtes enivré monsieur nous n'avons vu que
les fonds de bouteilles paso si tu
pouvais faire entendre qu'il n'y a pas
de coteau non deux comme ça sans
assister à modérer l'ardeur de mes
créanciers traitera des codes des
conditions t'enlève extec le cac rugby
si l'eau pourrie par an monsieur bergé
rue défi saint thomas
1 je parie que celui là le père cru mot
peut annoncer l'arrivée de monsieur
gotoh juste as-tu forte mais surtout que
personne ne nous dérange avant que je
naisse avec bien et maintenant me sonne
à nouveau la vie n'a plus la police
c'est rassurez vous c'était pour vous
bien réveillé qu'est ce qui a vous ne
trouvez pas ça drôle hein tant pis moi
j'adore ce genre de plat mais je n'ai
même plus que ça se travaille
alors je m'assieds papa monsieur
l'excessive habileté n'est pas la
délicatesse la délicatesse t'es pas la
légèreté la légèreté des paluns probité
et tout ça ça couple se confond à la
perfection les longues sont interceptés
dépourvu pour s'arrête au code c'est le
succès venez on devient une espèce de
héros nouveau papa vous entrez dans la
conscience vous êtes ma pensée que
voulez vous de moi je vais vous sauver
comment soyez l'homme qui se content
d'être à pour moi les hommes de paille
peuvent brûler à betty dont soyez un
promu stib
comment se fera le partage sa mémoire je
vous renvoie 47 1200 propre à 39
centimes
et entre nous vous n'aurez qu'à montrer
un petit peu d'athlètes au pistolet à
l'épée au sablou donc à personne à tuer
ça me va faire revivre un énorme ça ne
va plus du tout non toutes les femmes
qui font rire aujourd'hui au théâtre
sont très mal prise et dans la vie
réelle on y mêle des commissaires de
police qu'on leur pose plus depuis
l'abolition des privilèges c'est la
seule tares du socialisme et à mon petit
vieux cinq ans de taule dans un cachot
sortie de son enfin sans fin vous devrez
sable vous c'est ce que vous pourrez
faire de labriffe je suis encore pneus
mous conserve le droit de fonder des
entreprises ont l'esprit sera toujours
plus forte la loire et puis on jamais la
spéculation
je dirai à tous les semblables d'un seul
élan la majorité c'est moi
suivez moi voyez vous les gens qui
cherchent des millions en trouvera
difficilement mais ceux qui n'en cherche
pas on trouve jamais
que faut-il est une espèce donc
d'amérique à l'associer dans les halles
cc d'extraire vous achetez des actions
en baisse pour les revendre ferme
allemande mais j'ai la sphère sur social
autour de l'association les services
pour endosser les effets qu'ils
m'imposeront 18 sont en âge et ou même
trois temps qu il ya des risques
personne ne vous reconnaîtra écoutez je
prends vraiment rodez vous falloir
donner pour 49 1233 force tranquille je
vous en prie jeune homme a promis de ne
plus chercher la nuit repose-toi godeau
passé dans vos boudoir vous trouverez de
malan marocain marron hop dehors de papa
je vais vous mitonner un manitou inde ou
en sort seul oeuf le petit perçu
monsieur vers chez moi y'a eu baissière
sur les actions des biches de la base un
sensationnel mercadé vers de là on a
fait vendre quelques sud à 25% en
dessous de la cote a sous la panique ira
ce matin on ne saisit à la petite bourse
ces actions pc de 15% sur le cours
d'hier je prends deux mille actions et
oui mais il vous faudra 300 mille francs
à mener les actions
je perds dans la situation vous êtes
vous achetez évidemment pour go do you
do
j'ai appris qu'il était arrivé je sais
pas de reçu 5 est un savant jeu super q
comment avez vous appris le retour de
contour votre concierge que mont comi a
fait cause la voilà la faute je suis
impardonnable
j'ai oublié de lui fermer la bouche
d'une pièce un bon conseil mercadet fait
d'emporter sa voiture chez un carrossier
si vos créanciers la fois ils feront un
traitement alors je ne suis pas inquiet
pour avoir de l'argent frais seront
quelques petits sacrifices mercader une
idée nos traversé l'esprit
si si je traite pour godeau qu'il me
donne un ordre
ça suffira compétent il dort on m'a dit
tu seras réveillez vous aurez nord
l'affairé conclue goulard et deux autres
faiseurs m'ont donné mission de liquider
à tout préavis d'actions chez duval
setubal puis ta peau de mon chef m'a
fait l'affront de le prendre pour
banquier matthieu sublet ce cas mais
pour le dise il est plein de bonnes
intentions à mon sujet godault et doux
perçu on va recommencer à travailler
ensemble
jeune ou pas d'ici la fin de l'année
pour plus de 120 francs de courtage sous
puisse prendre de la basse indre pour
mon corps et poussé à la baisse dans la
coulisse fait insérer cette lettre dont
tous les journaux
elle fait état d'un rapport des
ingénieurs et thomas à l'ouverture de la
grande course dure à des actes ans pour
sandro ce nom d'arguments le secret sous
le retour de go de rom et démentent
hébergement et ces familles démantèlera
vivre il va le temps pourri des années
tu verras corta figure de chambre
mortuaire compter sur le mariage de
julie pour affirmer votre crédit k2 mais
les créanciers
les événements d'hier soir vous m alors
merci c'est le regarde pas puis je vous
être utile
l'a10 vivois vous vous promenez au bras
de méricourt et vous ignorez paris vous
tombez béatement dans ce traquenard
un lunch avec une bonne femme de ménage
aux bleus m utiles en est témoin d'un
ton super demandé une crèche
emmenez votre fille à l'aide il ya 50 ou
par le bagout donne les circonstances
présentes
les femmes portent elles ont des nerfs
elle vise en prime sans voix je veux
rester soit pas sa méfiance est papa cet
adage qui dit ouah bon que ce mineur
les jetables ou encore ma fille oui oui
monsieur
j'ai déclaré mon amour pour julien
monsieur duval il a prouvé mon choix il
a dit allez comme sa mère c'est une
saint jal va pas que julie est cousin
pauvre
oui mais j'avais monsieur sans le savoir
une petite fortune je vous écoute mon
ami lorsqu'elle me confiant jean duval
ma mère vu remis une somme qu'il a fait
fructifier au lieu de la consacrer à mon
entretien ce petit capital se monte
maintenant à 30 mille francs
sachant que j'ai prié monsieur duval de
me confier cette somme et je vous la
force car quelquefois avec des à côtés
on s'arrange domine à mon entrée dans
cette vision rapide pas trop mais on
pourrait les triplés en achetant des
actions du das faire deux là ne me
tentait pas vous ne tentez pas
je pouvais payer cent mille écus avec 39
francs la fortune de la france daniel
serez fait pas qu'est ce qu'il ya de
meilleur de votre argent vaut mieux que
vous vous voulez refusé il faut remonter
je vous en donne vous êtes entrés la
fille monsieur mark adams et merveilleux
puis je veux croire
vous entendez me julie voulait pondre et
quant à laura 3 semble frotte pas
monsieur mercadé vous jouer je vous jure
que non tant sa voix elle sera ok on
prend des mois c'est environ chez moi ce
portefeuille me démange cette façon
d'insister c'est affligeant
je peux te faire des enfants c'est mon
travail voilà quinze jours après la
visite mardi le service invité la femme
et julie pour le dîner un bac s kalou à
huy faut de l'argent pour les frais
la safra pauvres noirs de la monnaie
notre père voulait payer ses créanciers
s'il voulait renoncer aux affaires oui
aller vivre à la campagne
c'est la plus heureuse et souhaite
tranquille moment nous triompherons de
la bourse il faudra comme on va quand on
perd de tels événements que je ne serai
pas je suis lancé julie mal dans ma peau
je sens que je ne tiendrai plus leurs
hôtes temps on voit la couleur c'est le
mot le plus après le plus féroce que je
fonce magra me pardonnez moi de vous
apporte une et au parfum
je ne suis pas de ceux qui s'incruste je
viens me mettre aux ordres de mon cher
ami mercadet mais d'une politesse
exquise mon père en a sans doute trouvé
quelques stratagèmes je le crains
monsieur mercadé vanille
j'ai su l'événement notable qui changent
la face de vos affaires nous ignorons
tout rose et le violet vous êtes futé
j'ai déjà supprimés chez par mais non
l'associé série le voyageur coteaux est
arrivé comme moi si non vous vous avez
vu boîte d'euros et aironi riches va
vous le savez bien les partis chez lui
hier soir vous donner en guinée pour lui
mais il a été retardé
faut pas nous prendre pour des novices
ou même gotoh ici c'est moi j'ai vu ça
vers l'est oui maman j'ai vu une voiture
entrer cette nuit ça je regrette
monsieur mais personne n'est venu chez
moi cette nuit où tu reviens vous
entendez à merveille les intérêts de
mercadex vous à féliciter votre leçon
numéro est au point inutile il ne pourra
pas longtemps nous cacher coteaux nous
attendons un mois s'il le faut c'est
déjà la petite bourse nous nous sommes
réunis ce matin mes amis et moi nous
avons discuté notre sagacité frottements
cruel nous permet de tout avis n'est
parce que nous savons tous supposés
canto a pris donné l'action des mines
dans la passe un mauvais début on voit
bien qu'il débarque d un dîner plus dans
la place on avait si vous me parlez les
pourquoi vous parler français mais c'est
pas mauvais chiens
une petite différence sur macrez ans si
vous voulez me permettre de m'entendre
avec cotto fort monsieur je n'entends
rien aux affaires je vais avertir
monsieur merkel
je suis ta compagne
et côté rien vous épousez mademoiselle
mercadet duval maladie et si ce vieux ça
vous a conseillé le mariage c'est qu'il
connaissait l'arrivée gaubert suscite à
monsieur c'est vous qui m'apprenez le
retour de monsieur quant au temps est
bien considéré comme de la famille vous
êtes dans le complot du silence mais
cependant j'en suis certain ne lui
déplairait pas de servir mais reconnaît
alors fait on comprendra godeau que s'il
veut me payer sur le champ
je fais une remise de 20% écoutez
monsieur je ne me sens pas autorisé à me
mêler des affaires de monsieur mercan et
le prendrait très mal d'ailleurs le
voici
alors expliquez vous directement avec
ben pourquoi ça te dire
c'est un nous attend comme des presto la
campagne vous n'aurez jamais julie je
vous le promets à 12 boulot le duel sera
loyal alors cette fois-ci vous êtes tous
décidé à me faire des pauses et mobile
home il paraît que ce sui 1 faisait
souvent des hommes les plus capables de
paris un homme qui gagne des millions de
piles on aura un boom calendrier où vous
plaisantez oui je vois bien vous vous
moquez enfin vous ne vous êtes pas
réunis en assemblée pour deux pour vous
aider pour étudier les moyens soit pour
vous sortir d'embarras nous entendre mon
cher ami temps qu'il vous plaira combien
je regrette mon principe a du ballon
mais bien fait et le temps perdu mais ça
va pas juste
oui pas nous déranger moi combien se
rendre à tombera sur jambes bien fait
mais le temps perdu
gastien juste permettez second mandat de
monsieur monsieur violette notre style
oui si je lui arrange un rendez vous
êtes monsieur gotoh n'est ce pas
corrompre tu deviens larmes de père
cadets mais par la même occasion de thé
libre aussi celui là on le lui la
montboulard vous allez d'excusés juste
de te faire part d'un message vocal je
dois répondre par écrit
c'est d'une importance extrême dont le
j'ai compris monsieur essy fin combien
violet d'offres et il pourrait être mis
en présence le godot c'est pas vrai
monsieur c'est que nous aurons à nous
aussi donc non monsieur il ne m'a rien
fait quand at il donné maria tati
données pour travailler monsieur beer
cadet kim avait bien recommandé de terre
les retours de gounod je ne mentirai pas
monsieur
si louis aubert à 15 ans gars entrent en
compte dans ci-dessus poteaux pouvaient
revenir souvent mais c'est entendu je le
verrai le premier ici monsieur bien
l'attendre dans le vestibule gérer
l'avertir des que bordeaux sera là je
compte sur toi pour tes monsieur compte
et ils seront là comme le homard dans le
vivier jeu les plongeraient tous deux
dans les uns après les autres des pizzas
et paillettes pullulent dans mes paumes
dans les poches de mon pantalon
partout elle pousse qui grappille et
grignote grain graduellement vers le
plus grand grade
mais soyons s'agace la sottise se
saignent scientifiquement usant de ruse
et nous volerons carrosse du cran juste
un quart après car m
enfin du carré sera ta corne d'abondance
attendait les amours déçus il me dira
quand je pourrai leur laisser voir avant
garçon aura fait à cette fin mais
surtout une écoute afin d'être pro barça
sur un pieu godoy et moi nous avons à
débattre secrètement il va venir coni
son oreille à la porte bien j'aime paris
dit oui
je les gars
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette ressemblance avec auto tel que
celui là j après dix ans de séjour aux
hommes de la bri d'un poids mon auguste
cher mais qu'à des amis transcendant
l'amitié que l'afrique ce climat que ce
climat de valises ne trouvez vous pas si
monfils n'habitait pas ici jamais vous
n'aimeriez rêver mais il fallait bien
apprendre à ce petit que ça père et sa
mère se sont mal il s'appelle michel
nad-e-ali brive vous des parts et mais
pourquoi cet accent roumain
je vais attraper aux indes comment
voulez vous il faut savoir tout faire
quand on le regarde a pris juste a lieu
du zafira sur ce qu'est rideau le t2
monsieur costaud
monsieur pierre qu'un essai de
circonvenir le père renaud il veut
forcer notre portée ce faire elle n'a
pas de vertu une t il le souhaite le
premier membre fondateur de la société
du canal de se déporter cette lettre a
du mal
tiens je viens d'imiter la signature de
godot
je n'ose penser à ce qui adviendrait si
les actions de la basse indre restait
tout sous du père je vous le dis tout
net je sauterai dans les soutes du
premier bateau en partance pour les
indes la main je crois bien de mousse
hasard bombe aux basques autour de toi
c'est 50% pour le tournoi 50 pour chaque
une seule garde comme un capital de remy
d'insérer made est un excellent maire
kader cheveux je suis en affaires nous
savons avec kick ass vous on a des
filles avec l'aimable monsieur ghosn
on va voir avant voilà 1,30 à dormir a
su père violette je vous jure que
monsieur n'est pas beau dos quand
j'apprends vouloir à témoin de cette
déclaration il ment comme une publicité
de pâtes dentifrices mais en affaires
pour les coûts sont claires je sens sa
le commerce serait bien malade
mercado du sud est parvenu ces coteaux
de le reconnaître
dida selon la couleur finale tandis que
je ne souffrirai pas trop tourmente à
suite c'est tout à fait un indien
maintenant il a beaucoup changé
oh vous savez ce que c'est les aides ont
un effet foudroyant sous les gens
l'ennemi
les pestes désert clic la peste le team
le pavot n'ai pas pris coeur mais
personne qu'est ce que je raconte me
avez vous des papilles f au large et au
mont amine de longues capes et d'une
arrêtez messieurs arrêtez la mauvaise
plaisanterie sur le croit qui ne doit
laisser en rien vos intérêts pas grave
les cieux n'est pas de dolus vous êtes
du pied ou juste par anne intriguant
c'est pas possible
moi j'ai plus un centime vaillant j'ai
tout distribué par générosité de coeur
s'ils voulaient garder le silence sur
cette entreprise vous serez payés et
parquet s'il vous plaît ma petite par
monsieur di valle faul fam foyer se sent
chez lui
vous me trouverez et vous serez
satisfaits à mon âge on peut commencer à
croire au père noël
attention si ce n'est ce soir c'est bon
ton compte merkel madame si vous n'étiez
pas une femme
vous seriez déjà morte je suis monsieur
de la bri non c'est faux comment ça je
ne suis pas moi je ne veux pas savoir
qui vous êtes mais qui que vous soyez
vous apprécierez le service que je vais
me rendre mon mari vous fera cadeau de
vos titres
je suis au courant non retirés vous il
est temps que je demeure seul avec
monsieur mercadet nous avons un lourd
contentieux à régler nous aussi madame
je m'incline devant votre élégance
j'espère simplement que fo a salué cette
fable qui vous prend vous voulez briser
définitivement bts vous vous habituez
par enchantement
vous avez de rencontrer la planche à
billets de la banque de france non je
veux seulement que vous restiez celui
que j'estime que ce n'est direz vous que
des idées femme et vous me ferez la
grave les égoutter
je peux être encore 200 milles
comprenait les pour désintéresser vos
créances un vrai loup sont toujours
aussi pauvres que le peuple de spam qui
tourne cette atmosphère de mensonges
n'hésitez plein de me pousser à la
faillite
on sort l'air c'est ce qui me reste à
faire je ne quitterai pas auguste nous
luttons ensemble suivant j'ai perdu mon
père fait quelques bêtises compter sur
moi je lui fais un rop aurait dit le
toupet de nous cacher leur situation les
ter-gv modique monsieur va être arrêté
et moi je viens d économie solide et
nous allons tout perdre
c'est une faillite on suit si mich je
n'entends rien il parle trop bas et trop
fort monsieur se méfie toujours de nous
qu est ce que c est une espèce de vol
mettons à volonté est parfaitement
établi par la loi mais terriblement
aggravée par les formalités mais
rassurez vous monsieur liquide qu'est ce
qu'il fait lui qui dit la liquidation
c'est toujours la faillite mais qui se
complique par la constatation de la
bonne foi du débiteur ce qui supprime
les formalités
il sait tous et justin sont des phrases
à monsieur qui sont d'ici à trois ans
attendre en argent nous apporte moi
j'aime la mer que l opéra chercher ma
foi go prenez moins 20 degrés de froid
sur les joues au late est bien évident
de la bassin ne sont elles pas en
hausses sensationnelles mercadet nous
atteindrons opère ce matin c'est parti
et ça tape en plein dans le mille
le fenouillèdes on ignore jusqu'où il
prendra à votre lettre fait des
merveilles
la compagnie a flairé le coup elle va
déclarer à la bourse de résultats des
opérations de sondage et la mine de la
basse indre voguera celle de mons
belgique vous avez suivi nos conseils
combien avez vous pris pour vous 500
comme deux vsab nous a remis dans la
pause peut-être 100 francs madame b
rechute vous l'êtes en équipage
elle nouera mon cher les jolies femmes
qui vont appeler moi savenas temps sur
quelques châteaux saut à 10% au-dessus
du pet réaliser vous êtes la crème des
hommes
vous n'avez jamais fait de mal qu'à vos
actionnaires et accepter un autre
concert quitté la police
souvenez vous m'offrez de cette grande
phrase de l'évangile applicables aux
affaires celui qui se sert du glaive des
targuets au fond vous êtes un brave
homme
mais vous avez devant vous des ennemis
implacables à bochum a juré que c'était
un faux
à force à un faux pas mais ça ce n'est
pas forcément c'est signer demain matin
ainsi qu'au dos n'est pas à paris haufor
of the brave homme corps et j'ai du mal
à vous trouver l'argent qui vous est dû
pour les deux options si je suis payé je
remettrai s'étendra du val
mais mon cher mercadet je prierai pour
vous que god aussi trouva je vais chez
duval au genre pullulent sur les
positions stratégiques préparer à
l'avant ce genre propre montage des
généraux qui manoeuvre est toujours
aussi chers sont tous ces actes
seulement à saisir je t'aime tant vu mon
centre un foyer vous appelle déjà mon
gendre
vous savez tout pour rester duval obtenu
de lui qui paie et satisfasse pire chute
ce qui sauve et je vole à votre secours
oh
[Musique]
les miss avance en rangs serrés
j'aurais dû me carapater comme je me
préférait rêveur bucolique dans les bois
de vie d'abord enfin faisons face
dieujuste 1 qui perd un bon mètre je ne
suis pas encore assez forts pour quitter
monsieur ma femme s'est elle a quitté
d'escale pour virginia la tête si dur
avec l un et un font toujours 3 on n'est
pas prêt de le démontrer car un et un
font hop propres aux marchands et sact
quand on ajoute les intérêts les
mathématiques comme tu vois sont une
science exacte
comme monsieur m'amuse il a le malheur
spirituel mon admirable monsieur meerkat
et whip ergonet tout finit par casser
même les ans va en prison je ne serai
pas seul
la compagnie nombreuses on lire en
compte tous les déchets tous les génies
des tapis non non et non des acteurs que
vous sont rares vous devriez ma
difficile font payer les intérêts les
frais tous arrivés sur monde à je m'en
veux d'avoir critiqué beaucoup crié je
m'en veux de mes pleurs de mais jérémy à
2000 doute
j'avais une excuse je ne croyais plus en
retours de bottés pour violer
l'apaisante rue etc et mercadet vous est
sublime
je vous ai méconnu je suis à votre
dévotion n'est pas leur ai même pas vos
sacs à l'état ya on n'insistera pas
défaut dans la fosse on se vend jeunes
c'est la phrase moi je ne dis qu'un bon
parfait où les fier d'être ton ami vous
êtes le partenaire le plus correct qu'il
soit possible de rencontrer dans nos
métiers c'est bien simple
je voudrais vous laissez tout mon action
nous aurions tout sur des quelque chose
et vous n'avez rien demandé vous êtes
l'intégrité la soirée présentation la
petite fille et serviable avec sa
servillat comme il n'est pas possible
ah ça messieurs vous êtes voix c'est
beau c'est de moi voyez temps qu'il vous
plaira amusez-vous de ce mannequin sa
défense vous m'avez fait de venir et je
mords est bonne et puisque d'être à unir
l'assemblée pour celui l'analyse je
déclare que votre chi pièce se défendra
avec deux jours d'écart si vous ne
m'attendais pas d'aider les joues couple
accord comment vous remboursez
d'arguments monde j'ai tout le monde a
été payé par kodak antonio gaudi cet ami
tu as spectre érigeant une fantasmagorie
vous le savez tous aussi pleine il est
arrivé
de calcutta oui avec une fortune un
calcul tard il part dans mercadet mon
chéri remplaçable
voici vos actions elles ont été payées
par tous et par godeau quand vous me
l'aviez annoncé 150 mille francs
nous sommes au père j'avais vu content
mais oui il m'a dit que ces actions
étaient à vous comprends ni même
débarqué du hard way laventie danse
mercadet je n'aurais pas mon appartement
mais tant pis je reçus chez les fous
ados qui ne trompera pas fallu voir un
charme opère mon père est à paris il a
épousé ma mère m'a reconnu pour fils
légitime
je me nomme désormais adolphe godeau la
rembourser tous ces messieurs tous
complètement inaperçue et vous supplie
de conserver ses actions
un titre d'acompte sur votre part dans
les bénéfices de ces entreprises aux
indes
salut fortune reine des rois impératrice
des emprunts princesse des actions et
maire du crédit fortune c'est forcément
des heures de queue tu devais venir gens
se souhaiter que vous me conserverez
votre confiance
il est qu je les laisse à julie pour
deux boutons il devient reconnaissant il
n'est pas reconnaissable ma part c'est
épouvantable adolphe et millionnaire et
il veut m'épouser
je ne sais pas si je dois accepter c'est
pas faux qu'est-ce que d'émotions c'est
rapport à 4 ans est courageux dans la
version à je suis en france dont la joie
de te voir et chez souvent riche mais
honnête honnête
finalement c'est tout simple je suis
tombé sous tend le fatigue l'esprit
toujours traduit toujours sur les armes
un scellant ribéry maintenant j'aspire
au repos mon père vient d'acheter une
terre antoine soyez son voisin c'est
comme lui imiter le oui c'est ça mon âme
est le cas le les silences de la coop il
dit ennuiera après les fonds publics
les fonds de terre la mise en valeur des
produits alimentaires l'aménagement du
territoire
le lancement d'un emprunt pour le
développement de l'arrosoir de l'inta
tisseur dividende est électrique dans
les bronches war l'agriculture
n'occupera il faut organiser les
circuits de distribution rationaliser
leur haka de sa carrière salle du minage
à tuer la fertilisation
je ne suis pas fâché d'étudier cette
industrie là moi j'achète à court terme
notait une voiture j'ai tant de fois
montré godeau que j'ai bien le droit de
voir vous même monsieur allons voir
qu'au dos
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
mesdames messieurs la pièce que nous
venons de jouer devant vous dans une
adaptation nouvelle et une mise en scène
de pierre franck régate honoré de balzac
avec valentine ducret
mais on le sac
jean péméja
aussi se chauffe eau
équipe bis
[Applaudissements]
martin coup dur
tant mieux
[Applaudissements]
halima stu
cent-vingt militants
jacques tu siro
henri douaniers
jean-marie bernicat
patrick bourgeois
en soi ce fleury
[Applaudissements]
et jean le boulot
[Musique]